Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlaff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 130 vom 13.
März 2025. Zwei Wochen ist es her, dass wir eine Sendung gemacht haben über die Ukraine.
Ich und Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Und da waren wir ganz froh, dass wir endlich mal alles so vom Tisch geräumt
haben, damit dann erstmal irgendwie Ruhe ist und dann kann man ja nochmal gucken,
ob irgendwas passiert. Und dann brach die Hölle los.
Und leider gab es in den letzten zwei Wochen bis jetzt keine Gelegenheit,
für uns nochmal zusammenzukommen, auch wenn sich irgendwie täglich immer mehr ergab und aufstaute.
Und schon bei der Vorbereitung dieser Sendung haben wir gemerkt,
oh Mann, das ist einfach fast alles überhaupt gar nicht mehr ordentlich zusammenfassbar.
Wir wollen es aber trotzdem probieren, mit anderen Worten, wir blicken darauf,
was sich in der internationalen Geopolitik so ergeben hat.
Und dieser Podcast ist mal, also zumindest diese Serie.
Also dieser Teil dieses Podcasts, diese Season, die wir hier gerade durchziehen,
dieser Fokus auf die Ukraine,
begann mal eben mit einem Fokus auf den Krieg selbst und auf ein Geschehen,
von dem wir glaube ich beide so ein bisschen das Gefühl hatten,
dass am Anfang dem nicht genug Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt wurde und dass das irgendwie
wichtig ist. und dass das irgendwie besonders ist.
Und dann haben wir drei Jahre lang jetzt auch dabei zugeschaut,
wie eigentlich alle Beteiligten und speziell natürlich Europa und da vor allem
auch Deutschland sich also gewunden haben und irgendwie diesem Thema nie so
richtig die Aufmerksamkeit zu geben schienen,
die es unserer Meinung nach gerecht werden würde.
Ja und dann ging es los.
Einen Tag nachdem wir diese letzte Sendung veröffentlicht haben,
gab es jetzt dieses epische Streitgespräch im Oval Office zwischen Trump und Vance und Zelensky.
Und seitdem ist alles anders und man hat das Gefühl, wir treten in ein neues
Zeitalter der Geopolitik ein.
Und ja, das werden wir jetzt mal versuchen, ein bisschen zusammenzufassen.
Das wird jetzt nicht vollständig sein, aber so ein bisschen unsere Gedanken
darauf zu richten, was hier vielleicht jetzt die relevantesten Aspekte und Überlegungen
sind, was wir da so von zu halten haben,
was wir auch so an Meinungen around the world mitgenommen haben.
Ja, und ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir groß zum Orakeln kommen, wie das jetzt so weitergehen wird.
Auf jeden Fall kann man schon mal festhalten, dass der relativ optimistische
Blick, den man durchaus hätte haben können, sich so nicht ergeben hat.
Eigentlich war das ja so eine Art 30 Zentimeter vom Golfloch entfernter Putt,
den man da noch hätte machen müssen,
um irgendwie Russland zu diesem Zeitpunkt dort eingefangen zu bekommen.
Aber offensichtlich hat sich die US-Regierung das alles ganz anders vorgestellt
und jetzt laufen sie irgendwie wild in die andere Richtung und zerstören dabei
ja nicht nur das Porzellan im Porzellanladen,
was wir letztes Mal schon im Titel beschworen haben,
sondern jetzt bleibt eigentlich überhaupt nichts mehr heile.
So würde ich das mal einführen, das Thema heute. Was denkst du?
Ja, ich meine, es war auch schon die Rede so von Firehose of Bad Ideas,
die so aus dem weißen Haus kommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da eine brauchbare deutsche Übersetzung gibt,
weil Firehose ist halt Feuerwehrschlauch.
Also jedenfalls eine Flut, nennen wir es einfach eine Flut schlechter Ideen,
von der wir überrollt worden sind und wo es jeden Tag irgendwie anders ist.
Und ja, es war auch schon die Rede von...
Der Dunning-Kruger-Regierung, wo die von massiver Selbstüberschätzung und wenig
Faktenkenntnis geprägt ist.
Und ja, wo mein Soziologe würde man sagen,
dass es sich um einen Haufen Leute handelt, wo deren Wirkmächtigkeit leider
deren Wissensmächtigkeit bei Weitem überschreitet.
So macht es jedenfalls den Eindruck.
Und ja, deswegen fürchte ich, ein Großteil der Sendung wird auch darin bestehen,
zu erklären, warum die meisten dieser Dinge wirklich schlechte Ideen sind oder zu fragen,
was steckt denn überhaupt dahinter.
Die halbe Welt versucht jetzt irgendwie Sinn in das hinein zu interpretieren,
was da passiert und fragt sich jetzt,
was steckt dahinter, was ist die große Strategie, was sind die Ziele so oder
ist Trump einfach nur verrückt geworden?
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich ein Problem.
Und das werden wir versuchen, irgendwie ein bisschen rauszuarbeiten heute.
Ich hoffe, dass uns das ein Stück weit gelingt.
Aber irgendwie haben wir es ja mit viel Chaos und viel Wahnsinn zu tun.
Das ist so mein Eindruck, der gerade in der Weltpolitik vorherrscht und vor
allen Dingen von der US-Regierung ausgeht.
Genau, es rächt sich jetzt viel Unterlassenes. Das kommt noch dazu.
Ja, steigen wir vielleicht mal ein mit eigentlich einem Begleitgeschehen,
was erstmal nur so ein bisschen den Kontext liefert, weil seitdem jetzt die
Trump-Regierung am Start ist,
macht es eben den Eindruck, als ob sie dieses Project 2025, was wir glaube ich
auch in einer der vorvorletzten Sendungen kurz nach der Wahl oder vor der Wahl, ich weiß nicht,
hast du das glaube ich auch noch mal aufgezählt und ich dachte nur so,
oh Gott Pawel, sei ruhig irgendwie, so schlimm wird es doch nicht kommen, aber,
sieht so aus, als ob jetzt der Plan dann doch abgearbeitet wird und das ist
schon das wäre schon fast auch noch mal eine eigene Sendung wert,
glaube ich, aber also ob wir die machen, weiß ich nicht, aber.
Der ganze Umfang der Maßnahmen der sich vor allem jetzt innenpolitisch in den
USA erstmal mal so entfacht.
Also dieser ganze Purge, der halt von Doge ausgeht und also diesem merkwürdigen
Projekt von Elon Musk, der ja gar nicht gewählt wurde,
aber trotzdem aus irgendwelchen Gründen auf einmal eine Exekutiv-Power zugestanden
bekommt und anfängt, irgendwelche Leute zu entlassen und komplette Behörden einzustellen,
allen voran halt USAID,
wo sich schon mal gezeigt hat, okay,
das wird auch alles geopolitische Auswirkungen haben.
Weil gerade USAID als Organisation ist an der Stelle schon extrem delikat.
Was ist das? Das ist so eine Organisation, die halt eigentlich im Wesentlichen
dazu da ist, wie der Name schon sagt, Hilfe über der Welt zu verteilen.
Das geht von, wir kaufen den amerikanischen Farmern ihren Weizen ab und schippern
den halt in Säcken, wo schon in den USA draufsteht, um die Welt,
um halt Hunger entsprechend einzudämmen,
bis hin zu wir finanzieren unabhängigen Journalismus weltweit in Ländern,
wo halt sonst irgendwie kaum ordentlicher Journalismus betrieben wird.
Ja, das ist mehr oder weniger über Nacht alles komplett mit dem Arsch eingerissen worden.
Mittlerweile ist es so, dass wohl die Gerichte zumindest sichergestellt haben,
dass bereits zugesagte Gelder auch fließen müssen.
Aber es wird halt in dem Sinne keine neuen Aktionen geben.
Und allein das ist natürlich schon mal ein ganz schlimmes Signal an die Welt,
die im Prinzip besagt, ja, wir sind es die USA, we just don't care.
Weil damit kaufst du dir natürlich halt auch viel Goodwill und dieser Goodwill,
der ist halt jetzt hier auch innerhalb weniger Tage vernichtet worden.
Ja, plus, was halt so ein bisschen idiotisch ist,
USID war auch eine gute Gelegenheit, CIA-Agenten im Ausland operieren zu lassen, überall.
Das heißt auch, Informationen zu sammeln und einen Einfluss zu nehmen.
Und ja, da haben sie halt auch das Kind so ein bisschen mit dem Bade ausgeschüttet
und wahrscheinlich jetzt die USA von vielen Geheimdienstinformationen abgeschnitten, weil...
Die die Leute einfach alle zurückgeholt und entlassen haben,
was auch ein bisschen dämlich ist, also haben damit einen wichtigen Teil ihres
Spionagenetzes verloren.
Ja, aber das ist ja alles der Deep State und man hat den Eindruck,
dass also jetzt hier wirklich mit der Abrissbirne,
die Government-Strukturen zerstört werden und da steckt halt auch eine Ideologie
dahinter, die halt eben von diesen ganzen,
Geldmenschen, die jetzt hinter diesem ganzen Project 2025 und natürlich auch
der neuen US-Regierung stehen, also nicht nur Trump, sondern halt auch von J.D.
Vance, der ja von Peter Thiel im Prinzip protegiert wurde, schon mit viel Geld
zu seinem Senatsposten gebracht wurde und letzten Endes hintenrum eben dann
auch als Vizepräsidentschaftskandidat durchgesetzt wurde.
Und das ist halt einfach der lange politische Arm jetzt dieses Geldadels,
der hintenrum eine Ideologie vertritt, die einen nur noch gruseln lassen kann.
Das sind wir auch in den Kommentaren nochmal darauf hingewiesen worden.
Dass halt einfach hier diese Leute im Prinzip die Auflösung des Staates fordert, mal kurz gesagt.
Es gibt ja jetzt auch diese ganze Diskussion, wir richten jetzt Freedom Cities
ein, wie sie das so schön nennen, also so Gebiete, die quasi wie so ein Freihandelshafen,
der keinen Zöllen unterliegt.
Hast du dann quasi jetzt auch noch komplette Städte oder Regionen,
die dann eben nicht mehr den Gesetzen des Staates zu folgen haben und so weiter.
Also im Prinzip wollen sich hier die ganzen Milliardäre weitere Freiräume,
als ob sie nicht schon genug hätten, weitere Freiräume schaffen lassen.
Und ja, da stört natürlich erstmal ein regulierender,
eingreifender Staat mit einer funktionierenden juristischen Power und das ist
halt genau das Playbook, was man jetzt sieht.
Also es werden halt Richter diskreditiert, Elon Musk ist da täglich am twittern,
wie schlimm ja die Richter sein und überhaupt man müsste ja mal hier die Justiz abschaffen,
weil die ist ja irgendwie gegen die Freiheit und so werden halt Stück für Stück
derzeit alle Entitäten im US-Staat außer Gefecht gesetzt, die in irgendeiner Form.
Trump dabei behindern könnten, einfach seinen Willen durchzusetzen.
Und letzten Endes werden sie wahrscheinlich auch noch irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass.
Dass er dann sozusagen auch noch eine dritte Amtszeit antreten kann,
was ja eigentlich von der Verfassung her unmöglich ist.
Also ich sehe da wirklich maximalen Schaden zukommen und der kann auch teilweise
sehr irreversibel sein.
Hier haben sich also jetzt wirklich die Wahnsinnigen durchgesetzt und es ist vollkommen unklar.
Ja, also diese Leute sind der Meinung einfach, dass Demokratie ein schlechtes
System ist, weil zu viele arme und dumme Leute dort mitzureden haben und deswegen,
ja, es ist halt ineffizient und eigentlich braucht man Leute gar nicht und Staat und so.
Also es erinnert so ein bisschen mich auch viel an den Cyberpunk der 90er,
also viele Gesellschaftsentwürfe dort,
wo, ja, die Gesellschaft dort war alles privatisiert.
Du hast dich dann halt quasi einer Sicherheitsorganisation angeschlossen.
Also Polizei ist auch privat und du quasi zahlst dann an irgendeine,
statt eine Versicherung zahlst du eben dann auch an eine bestimmte Polizeigruppe
oder Machtgruppe, um dann eben deren Sicherheit zu haben.
Und wie gesagt, alles ist komplett
durchprivatisiert und den Staat gibt es eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Und das ist so ein bisschen deren Vision. Ja,
und dazu versuchen sie gerade dem Staat maximalen Schaden zuzufügen und das
scheint zu einem gewissen Maße auch zu gelingen,
auch wenn sie dabei extrem inkompetent vorgehen.
Das merkt man halt auch.
Aber ja, wir hatten ja beim letzten Mal,
glaube ich, auch schon darüber erzählt, wie Doge halt diverse E-Mails dann an
Mitarbeiter verschickt hat im öffentlichen Dienst. Ja.
Die erste E-Mail, die rumging, war ja diese Fog in the Road E-Mail.
Im Prinzip eine Kopie dessen, was Musk bei Twitter gemacht hat.
Im Prinzip wo drin stand, sie titelt Fog in the Road.
Also ihr müsst euch jetzt entscheiden, entweder ihr reißt euch jetzt den Arsch
auf, macht Überstunden und liefert halt maximale Exzellenz.
Und wenn ihr nicht dazu bereit seid, klickt hier, dann kriegt ihr noch eine
Abfindung und dann tschüss.
Und ich glaube, ungefähr 75.000
Mitarbeiter im öffentlichen Dienst haben tatsächlich dieses angenommen.
Aber ja, das hat man dann auch erzählt,
vielen einigen wurde das zum Verhängnis, weil statt Abfindung wurden sie einfach
dann rausgeschmissen ohne Abfindung, weil sie da draufgeklickt hatten.
Aber die, ich sag mal, Skriptkiddies, die Musk da losgeschickt haben,
waren auch in vielerlei Weise inkompetent.
Und ein Ding, was sie programmiert haben, ist,
dass sie jede Antwort auf die E-Mail im Prinzip als Zustimmung interpretiert
haben, was dann aber ein Problem dargestellt hat für Out-of-Office-E-Mails.
Wenn also irgendjemand, und das waren so fünf bis zehn Prozent,
waren halt gerade in Urlaub oder irgendwie auf Dienstreise und hatten halt eine
Out-of-Office-E-Mail.
Und diese Out-of-Office-E-Mails wurden dann interpretiert als ich nehme das Angebot an und kündige.
Woraufhin die Leute dann Mails kriegten, ja, hier, Sie haben das Angebot angenommen,
hier bitte, das sind die nächsten Schritte, was zu tun ist.
Was im Endeffekt dazu geführt hat, dass jetzt im öffentlichen Dienst der USA
niemand mehr Out-of-Office-E-Mails benutzt.
Aus Angst, dass irgendwie die Out-of-Office-E-Mail versehentlich wieder eine
Kündigung als Kündigung interpretiert wird.
Das könnte man auch als Verbesserung ansehen, weil Out-of-Office-E-Mails fand
ich schon immer ein absolut störendes Element. Das könnte man wirklich mal wegfallen.
Ja, aber selbst an solchen Details oder bei solchen Dingen, die einfach,
nicht passieren sollten, sieht man, wie undurchdacht, wie überhastet,
wie dämlich sie vorgegangen sind bei dem Ganzen.
Aber jetzt könnte man sagen, ja klar, gut, sie wollen ja eigentlich nur alles
kaputt machen, von daher ist das ja nur gut und richtig so.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie wirklich so denken.
Und das andere Perverse ist ja, dass sie in Wirklichkeit ja den Staat brauchen,
um ihre Macht auszuüben.
Also insofern schießen sie sich ins eigene Bein damit gerade.
Ja gut, teilweise wollen sie halt einfach erstmal die Systeme schwächen und
dann im Zweifelsfall halt einfach Leute installieren, die nach ihrer Nase tanzen.
Das ist dann der nächste Schritt.
Schwäche sie erstmal und vor allem halt auch so ein bisschen,
wie die ganze Trampsche Kommunikationspolitik ist, erstmal alle in Unruhe versetzen,
alle erstmal zu aufgeschreckten Hühnern machen.
Ja, weil in dem Moment sind sie natürlich auch hochgradig vulnerable und dann
kann man eben auch entsprechende Änderungen an Strukturen schneller durchführen.
Das ist halt einfach so eine Shock and Awe Taktik auch dabei.
Ich denke, das hat durchaus schon auch System.
Und klar, da mögen jetzt solche Fehler passieren, aber die führen am Ende auch
nur zu noch mehr Chaos, Verwirrung und Angst.
Und ja, da werden sie dann einfach draufhalten und dann in dem zweiten und dritten
Schritt das alles schon so biegen, wie sie das haben wollen.
Aber jetzt haben halt alle erstmal Schiss.
Ja, und jetzt ist halt die Frage, wie darauf überhaupt noch reagiert werden kann.
Also die demokratische Partei scheint derzeit überhaupt gar kein Rezept zu haben
Und die Gesellschaft, naja, es gibt so ein paar Proteste, aber die hat jetzt
auch noch keine Skalierung, die wirklich einen Unterschied machen würde.
Und mittlerweile geht ja Trump auch dann schon gegen Universitäten vor,
also nach dem Motto, wer hier protestiert, der wird dann irgendwie,
ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie war jetzt die Regelung, also entweder werden
die Leute sofort festgenommen oder das gibt es ja jetzt auch schon,
dass Protestierende einfach so festgenommen werden, so einfach ohne Anklage, gab es einen Fall,
dann gab es die Drohung, glaube ich, gegenüber den Universitäten,
dass sie dann irgendwie ihre Gelder verlieren oder dass sie irgendwie die Studenten
kündigen oder ich weiß nicht ganz genau, das habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht im Detail mitbekommen.
Permanent werden einfach weitere Drohungen aufgehäuft und es wird also permanent
das Recht gebeugt, sodass die Richter da gar nicht hinterher kommen.
Ja, es passiert halt einfach auch, ich sag mal, kompletter Schwachsinn,
das mit der Enola Gay, hast du da mitbekommen, dass die Bilder von der Enola Gay abgehängt haben.
Das war ja das Flugzeug, das die Atombombe über Hiroshima abgeworfen hat und
Enola Gay war die Dame der Mutter des Piloten gewesen.
Aber weil da das Wort Gay drin vorkam, haben sie das jetzt abgehängt.
Ja, nicht nur ein Bild abgehängt, sondern sie löschen ja auch aktiv Webseiten.
Also sie streichen alles, was ihrer Meinung nach vogue ist, aus Webseiten raus.
Es werden aber auch historische Archive gelöscht, eben auch Fotos,
unter anderem eben dieses weltberühmte Foto von dem Piloten,
der da vor der Maschine stand, die Atombombe abgeworfen hat.
Also es gibt überhaupt keinerlei Kenntnis irgendwie über Geschichte,
über Bedeutung und da wo sie existiert, dann wird sie eben vielleicht auch bewusst
als Waffe eingesetzt und es wird jetzt einfach auch eine Geschichtskletterung damit gemacht.
Also die Verluste auf kultureller Ebene und eben was den Staatsapparat betrifft,
die werden glaube ich noch lange zu spüren sein.
Also irgendwann wird glaube ich mal versucht werden,
hoffentlich, ich gehe davon aus, irgendwann wird das halt stattfinden,
irgendwann wird man versuchen diese ganzen Verluste dieser Monate und vielleicht
auch Jahre rückgängig zu machen und das dürfte schwierig werden.
Ja, was ich auch ziemlich übel finde,
so das I am Ende von DEI steht halt für Inclusion, was halt vor allem Einbeziehung Behinderter angeht.
Das heißt, es geht halt auch um eine behindertenfreundliche Politik.
Und das heißt, dass quasi deren DEI-Kreuzzug ist faktisch ein Felszug gegen Leute,
die nicht weiß sind,
gegen Frauen und gegen Behinderte.
Ja, so kann man das nur charakterisieren.
Und es ist jetzt auch nicht so,
dass das irgendwie jetzt ausgeufert wäre
und dass jetzt gerade in den
USA eine zu behindertenfreundliche Politik
oder eine zu frauenfreundliche oder zu ausländerfreundliche oder nicht-weißenfreundliche
Politik dort stattgefunden hätte.
Aber aus deren Sicht ist das halt alles viel zu viel.
Das ist Teil dieser rechten Geschichtserzählung in den USA, sodass ein Kampf
gegen die Weißen stattfindet.
Und das jetzt so sozusagen, die Weißen müssen jetzt Angst haben,
dass sie irgendwie von diesen Minderheiten überwältigt werden.
Das ist ja so diese ganze Erzählung, Umfolgerung.
Great Replacement Theory.
Genau, also das steckt ja überall mit drin. Und natürlich alle Leute,
die sich sozusagen für diese Menschen einsetzen, das sind dann aber alle Linke.
Und Linke sind alle die Feinde.
Und die sind ja die Feinde von Amerika. Also das ist ja in sich irgendwie auch
eine geschlossene Erzählung, die halt permanent eingehämmert wird.
Und die bei vielen Leuten auch einfach verfängt.
Und jetzt sieht man natürlich auch,
dass einfach jetzt so Jahrzehnte der Genügsamkeit und dieser Konsumrealität
und der Ignoranz der Weltrealitäten hat jetzt einfach ein Volk hervorgebracht,
was einfach zu großen Teilen auch einfach überhaupt gar keine Ahnung mehr hat,
wie die Welt funktioniert und was einfach normal ist auf diesem Planeten oder normal sein sollte.
Oder was auch nur die Realität innerhalb des eigenen Landes ist.
Und das ist eben die Bevölkerungsschicht, die diese Wahl von Trump getragen
hat und die jetzt sozusagen auch nochmal bedient wird oder denen jetzt sozusagen
all diese ganzen Maßnahmen, die eigentlich nur dazu da sind,
Geld von den Armen zu den Reichen weiter zu transportieren, verkauft wird eben
unter diesem Label des Kampfes gegen diese bösen Strukturen,
die überhaupt gar keine bösen Strukturen sind.
Ja, während es in Wirklichkeit, glaube ich sagen, ja,
um eine Realitätsfluchtkrise handelt, wo weder Fakten noch logische Schlüsse aus, sagen wir,
irgendwie eine Rolle spielen, wo man das Gefühl hat, einfach da sind Verrückte
am Werk oder sind Leute am Werk,
deren Gehirn irgendwie auf einem anderen Level operiert.
Ja,
zumindest ein bisschen Backlash gibt es ja. Also die Leute, besonders gut sind
die Umfragen für Trump jetzt nicht. Das ist alles noch nicht im kritischen Bereich.
Das reicht jetzt noch nicht, um die Republikaner Angst vor einer verlorenen Wahl zu erzeugen.
Aber ich glaube so Elon Musk persönlich kommt jetzt nicht besonders gut an.
Also an Tesla manifestiert sich derzeit auch so ein bisschen der Widerstand.
International, aber eben auch in den USA, also da brennen gerade viele Teslas
und Tesla-Stromtankstellen und so weiter.
Ja, ich meine, gut, die Leute wollen einfach kein Auto fahren,
das als rollender Nazi-Ghost wahrgenommen wird und deswegen auch Kampagnen,
so wie der Swastika und ja,
und dann massiver Absatzrückgang überall, vor allem in Europa,
Deutschland irgendwie minus 70 bis 80 Prozent.
So Kanada genauso, also gerade die Kanadier schäumen natürlich.
Und ja, in den USA organisierte Proteste an sehr vielen Tesla-Vertretungen,
so Tesla-Händler werden regelmäßig,
ja,
nicht bestreikt, Aber haben blockiert mit Demonstranten davor,
was natürlich auch nicht unbedingt gut ist für den Absatz.
Das ist natürlich deutlich auch noch zusätzlich geschäftsschädigend.
Ja, da macht man natürlich nicht viel.
Und dann, ich meine, da gehen wir vielleicht lieber dann detailliert in der
nächsten Sendung drauf ein, aber es ist auf jeden Fall zu erwähnen,
dass die Deportationen, die Trump auch angekündigt hatte von sogenannten illegalen Ausländern,
erstens viele Nicht-Illegale getroffen haben.
Unter anderem auch drei Deutsche, die einreisen wollten, die dann Tage bis Wochen
lang dann in irgendwelchen Abschiebelagern gehalten wurden.
Und die Krönung war, dass sie ungefähr 60 Leute, die ausreisepflichtig waren,
nach Guantanamo Bay geschafft haben.
Dort extra dann nochmal tausend Soldaten hingeschickt. Die ganze Aktion hat
16 Millionen Dollar gekostet wohl.
Dann sind Kongressabgeordnete da rausgeflogen, um das auch anzugucken.
Und dann haben sie aber festgestellt, das macht alles keinen Sinn.
Und haben die Leute alle wieder zurückgeflogen.
Das heißt, sie haben jetzt 16 Millionen ausgegeben, um mal für eine Woche 80
Flüchtlinge und tausend Soldaten nach Guantanamo Bay rauszuschaffen und wieder zurück.
So viel zu Department of Government Efficiency oder zum Thema Government Efficiency unter Trump.
Plus, dass natürlich, aber das gucken, dass natürlich gerade jetzt in vielen
ländlichen Regionen ihnen die Mitarbeiter fehlen.
Das hatten wir in der letzten Sendung auch schon erwähnt, aber das wird jetzt
wohl wird jetzt wohl ziemlich übel für die Agrarindustrie in vielen Staaten.
Es gibt Länder, also Bundesstaaten, wo bis zu 40 Prozent der in der Landwirtschaft
Beschäftigten illegale sind.
Die jetzt alle nicht zur Arbeit kommen. Und ja, aber das ist nochmal ein Thema
für sich, was vielleicht dann mal in der nächsten Sendung auffalten soll.
Ja, das bringt uns aber dann schon auch zu dem Thema des Handelskrieges,
die Trump jetzt losgetreten hat.
Und der sich auch irgendwie permanent wieder entwickelt.
Das haben wir natürlich in der letzten Sendung auch schon angesprochen.
Da gab es ja so den ersten Versuch, so ja, hier Kanada ganz böse,
Mexiko ganz böse, Ankündigung von entsprechenden Zöllen,
einen tollen Tariffs, sein Lieblingswort.
Da ist auch irgendwie da versteht irgendwie keiner so richtig was das eigentlich
alles soll also er hält das halt irgendwie für ein tolles Instrument um alle irgendwie,
ja wieder so in Schock und Ohr zu halten die ganze Zeit so schockieren und so
eine Ehrfurcht zu versetzen aber das gelingt auch nur so begrenzt.
Also Trump war schon immer ein Fan von Zöllen, das kann man irgendwie Jahrzehnte
sogar so bevor er seine politische Karriere begonnen hat sogar noch.
Aber Zelle findet Trump aus irgendwelchen Gründen richtig toll.
Macht aber so recht keinen Sinn. Speziell muss man natürlich jetzt erstmal die
Auseinandersetzung mit Kanada erwähnen.
Wir hatten das ja schon mal und da war es ja so, die Frühzeiten wurden angekündigt,
dann hat Kanada gesagt, dann werden wir entsprechend antworten und dann wurde
es erstmal wieder für 30 Tage zurückgenommen.
Dann ging das aber die ganze Zeit hin und her. Dann sollen sie doch wieder gelten,
dann sind sie höher, dann sind sie niedriger, dann werden sie doch wieder ausgesetzt
und so weiter und so fort.
Also wenn man sich jetzt mal so, ich habe mir mal so diverse Interviews mit
Vertretern der kanadischen Regierung angeschaut, speziell der Außenministerin,
aber auch der Premierminister,
der jetzt zurückgetreten ist und demnächst stehen noch Wahlen an. Also mal schauen.
Genau und durch Mark Carney ist er jetzt ersetzt.
Genau, er ist jetzt der Chef der liberalen Partei, die durchaus Chancen hat.
Auch wieder die nächste Wahl zu gewinnen. Aber das ist ja erstmal egal.
Auf jeden Fall, wenn man sich diese Interviews anschaut, dann merkt man so richtig, die Kanadier sind,
also das ist ja eigentlich ein sehr nettes Volk und so eine Höflichkeit,
damit kokettieren sie ja fast schon auch.
Gerade im Vergleich zu den eher rohen Amerikanern.
Aber wenn man sich eben die Reaktionen anschaut und was sie Interviews so von
sich geben, merkt man einfach, dass sie einfach total pissed sind.
Also das ist einfach, Trump hat es einfach komplett übertrieben. Also sie sind,
Richtig im Angriffsmodus, das fing halt schon an mit dem Ausbuhen der amerikanischen
Nationalhymne, wenn jetzt irgendwelche Hockeyspiele sind und kanadische Teams
gegen amerikanische Teams spielen, gut, das ist so ein bisschen nebenbei,
aber vor allem die krasse Ankündigung von Retaliation,
also von einer Auge um Auge, Zahn um Zahn Politik, die fand ich schon sehr bemerkenswert.
Weil jetzt natürlich auch die Wahlen anstehen, aber weil es eben auch wirklich
alle Kanadier komplett trifft,
auch across the board, also auch die Konservativen, die ja tendenziell den Republikanern
schon immer etwas näher standen, die nehmen kein Blatt vor den Mund,
sogar dieser Doug Ford, der ist der Gouverneur von Ontario,
so zugegebenermaßen der größten und wichtigsten Provinz da in Kanada, wo Toronto dazu gehört.
Eigentlich ein ziemlicher Holzkopf, aber auch der haut also kräftig drauf.
Und sie scheinen auch wirklich am längeren Hebel zu setzen, weil die USA brauchen eigentlich Kanada.
Die brauchen vor allem die Energie, die von dort kommt. Und so die Ankündigung
mit Strom kostet jetzt mal 25 Prozent mehr.
Und wenn ihr irgendwie nicht Ruhe gebt, dann gibt es irgendwie gar keinen Strom mehr.
Und uns auch egal, dann trifft uns das irgendwie hart. Wir werden schon irgendwie
da durchbeißen. Aber so wie ihr uns jetzt kommt, naja, braucht ihr uns gar nicht zukommen.
Also ich glaube, da wird es noch wild hergehen, aber dann eben auch dieses,
was glaube ich der Tipping Point war, war ja nicht diese Zölle,
sondern eben dieses Gehabe mit, ja Kanada ist doch eigentlich nur der 51.
Bundesstaat der USA. Und da war dann halt wirklich Ende Gelände.
Da sind die Kanadier dann komplett getillt und das werden sie den USA niemals verzeihen.
Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich...
Ein Punkt auf No Return gewesen. Die rechnen sich jetzt halt in vielerlei Hinsicht.
Nehmen irgendwie den ganzen Alkohol aus dem Regal, der aus den USA kommt.
Keiner will da mal hinreisen. Gibt irgendwie weitgehend Boykott.
Ja, also die letzten Zahlen sind, dass zum Beispiel die Flüge von Kanada in
die USA um 40 Prozent zurückgegangen sind.
Also die Passagieranzahl jetzt, seit das losgegangen ist.
Also das ist natürlich auch,
man hat in der letzten Sendung auch schon,
die Kanadier machen wohl den Großteil der US-Touristen aus und bringen irgendwie
20 Milliarden oder so im Jahr allein die Touristen nach Amerika.
Und das ist natürlich substanziell.
Genau, also Kanada wird sich schon zu wehren wissen.
In dem Zusammenhang, gerade in Bezug auf Zölle, war das für mich ganz interessant festzustellen, dass.
Dieses Zollproblem, was sie jetzt quasi mit den USA theoretisch haben,
weil ob die jetzt wirklich erhoben werden oder nicht, das geht ja die ganze Zeit hin und her.
Dann haben sie ja vor allem als Zuliefer der Automobilindustrie in den USA eine
wichtige Rolle. viele Autos passieren mehrfach, während sie produziert werden,
irgendwie die Grenze und so weiter.
Also deswegen ist Trump ja auch schon wieder zurück gegangen bei seinen Forderungen,
weil dann natürlich die Automobilindustrie angerufen hat und gesagt hat, habt ihr sie noch alle?
Ja, das wird jetzt hier einfach super teuer. Dann gab es dann irgendwie so einen
Spot auf Fox News, auf Fox Business, wo dann irgendein Händler gesagt hat,
ja, das Auto, das hat letzte Woche noch 80.000 gekostet, das muss ich jetzt für 100.000 verkaufen.
Weil sonst geht das ja gar nicht mehr. Und so Autos, das ist so bei den Amerikanern
ähnlich wie in Deutschland oder schlimmer eigentlich noch als in Deutschland.
Weil bei uns ist ja ein Auto, ich sag mal ein Luxusgut, was sich viele leisten.
Aber in den USA ist ein Auto quasi, wenn du keins hast, kannst du eigentlich
am Leben nicht teilnehmen.
Und deswegen trifft es da einfach so einen Nerv das ist halt wie ein Lebensmittel
dort und das kam irgendwie gar nicht gut an, deswegen ist er da sehr schnell
wieder zurückgezogen aber Kanada,
weiß einfach seine.
Kraft dort richtig anzusetzen und was er in dem Zusammenhang auch noch gelernt
habe ist dass es gibt das ist für dich absurd,
Wenn man das jetzt mal ausgerechnet hätte, was es Kanada gekostet hätte oder
kosten würde, würden jetzt all diese Zölle sozusagen aktiv werden.
Jetzt erstmal nur, was die USA Kanada quasi auferlegt.
Und das ausrechnet, was das für ein Schaden wäre, dann ist diese Summe geringer,
als der Schaden, der Kanada derzeit, und jetzt pass mal auf, an Zöllen entsteht.
Im interproventionellen Handel innerhalb Kanadas.
Weil Kanada seit Jahrzehnten auch innerhalb des Landes von Provinz zu Provinz,
also quasi Bundesstaaten, die kanadischen Bundesstaaten,
die haben sozusagen innerhalb Kanadas keinen Free Trade, sondern es gibt da
Handelsbeschränkungen.
Da wird seit Jahrzehnten hin und her geredet, aber alle Staaten halten sich sozusagen,
also alle Bundesstaaten, diese Provinzen halten sich natürlich wiederum für
das Beste und wollen dann irgendwie untereinander auch sich gegenseitig das Maximale abnehmen.
Und diese Hemmnisse existieren und kosten quasi die kanadische Wirtschaft sehr
viel mehr Geld als das, was jetzt sogar die USA quasi ihnen auferlegen möchte.
Völlig absurd. Was natürlich dann wiederum auch dazu führt, dass derzeit die
ganze Diskussion um die Aufhebung dieser innerkanadischen Zölle sehr gut vorankommt
und man davon ausgehen kann, dass sie demnächst komplett verschwinden werden.
Einfach um das schon mal zu kompensieren, was sie jetzt eben als Bedrohung durch
die Maßnahmen der USA auf sich zukommen sehen.
Aber solche Details, es ist wirklich krass und bestärkt mich auch immer wieder in diesem Glauben,
du brauchst einfach manchmal auch wirklich Großkrisen, um Länder nach vorne zu bringen.
Oder wie ich auch immer scherzhaft sage, Deutschland braucht eigentlich auch
mal einen Krieg, um irgendwie die Digitalisierung richtig hinzubekommen.
Alles andere scheint ja nicht zu funktionieren. Du brauchst irgendwie so ein
negatives Großereignis, um bestimmte Reformen überhaupt erst möglich werden zu lassen.
Und das sieht man jetzt in Kanada auch ganz gut.
Und was in Kanada, der Großteil der Bevölkerung lebt ja relativ nah an der Grenze.
Also die Bevölkerung konzentriert sich auf einen Streifen von Ost nach West entlang der Grenze,
sodass die einzelnen Provinzen wirtschaftlich teilweise engere Verflechtungen haben über die Grenze,
weil es schlichtweg näher ist als jetzt über die Breite des Kontinents.
Da haben sie dann jetzt auch beschleunigt unter anderem Ausbau von Verkehrsinfrastruktur
und wollen auch eine schnelle Zugverbindung, glaube ich,
dann von Ost nach West und so zwischen den Provinzen,
damit sie den innerkanadischen Handel jetzt ein bisschen mehr pushen.
Genau, also keine Krise sollte ungenutzt bleiben.
Das ist genau das, was ich meine. Also jetzt werden auf einmal Dinge getan,
weil eigentlich allen schon immer klar war, oh Mann, das hätten wir schon immer
machen sollen, siehe Deutschland, Schuldenbremse und so weiter.
Also wenn die Krise da ist, dann geht es auf einmal ganz schnell und bis dahin
ist es einfach immer nur so Politgeplänkel und irgendwie jeder versucht für
sich einen persönlichen Vorteil rauszuziehen zum Schaden aller.
Naja, also das ist auf jeden Fall die Situation mit Kanada. Mit Mexiko läuft
es ähnlich, aber ein bisschen stiller.
Während die Kanadier also sehr plakativ ihren Unmut zum Besten geben,
schafft es irgendwie die Scheinbaum in Mexiko mit stiller Diplomatie ganz gut,
die USA im Zaum zu halten. Weil auch da ist es natürlich auch genauso.
Die USA schaden sich mit der ganzen Politik nur selber.
Sie sind total darauf angewiesen, die Ressourcen aus Kanada zu bekommen und
sie sind total angewiesen darauf, billige Arbeit aus Mexiko zu bekommen.
Auch viele amerikanische Automobilhersteller produzieren natürlich in Mexiko.
Wie Deutschland ja auch.
Also es ist alles albern, aber trotzdem geht es immer weiter.
Und Trump hat natürlich auch China mit Söllen überzogen. Und jetzt als nächstes
ist dann halt auch noch die EU dran.
Ja, grundsätzlich ist die USA natürlich auch wirtschaftlich eine absolute Supermacht.
Und die Frage ist ja natürlich jetzt, wer kann länger durchhalten oder wem schadet es eigentlich mehr?
Und eigentlich so agieren sie schon aus einer Situation der Stärke heraus durchaus.
Nur ein Problem, was ich sehe, ist, dass sie diese Zölle halt auf alles machen.
Wobei, also die einzige Differenzierung war jetzt, dass Energie,
nur der halbe, ich glaube 10% auf Energie und 20 oder 25% auf alles andere war, sagen wir.
Im Falle von Kanada.
Im Falle von Kanada, genau. Und so Pauschalzölle zu erheben, ist einfach nicht klug,
weil was Länder jetzt quasi als Antwort dann auch geben, ist,
dass sie nicht eben Pauschalzölle erheben als Antwort, sondern gucken,
wo können sie Trump und den Republikanern und den republikanischen Staaten am meisten schaden.
Wo ist es am effektivsten? Wo tut es den USA am meisten weh?
Und das wird man jetzt halt abwarten müssen, wie sich das Ganze jetzt einpendelt.
Also im Moment ist es noch ein Hin und Her und Vor und Zurück und.
Ja, und was man aber, was man glaube ich auch sagen kann, ist,
dass mittlerweile Wall Street, die ja ungefähr 5% Zollerhöhungen eingepreist
hatten, wenn Trump kommt,
nun auch das unterschätzt haben, sagen wir mal so.
Und dementsprechend gab es erstmal die Erwartung, als Trump rangekommen ist,
sind die Aktien erstmal in die Höhe gegangen.
Auch Tesla, weil man angenommen hat, Elon Musk und wird das schon nutzen.
Das heißt, zwischen November und Mitte, Ende Dezember gab es eine riesen Kursrallye in den USA,
so Dow Jones Index und Tesla und so.
Und das ist aber mittlerweile wieder komplett weg.
Also jetzt sind wir an der Stelle, in den letzten Wochen ist dieser,
ich sag mal, Trump-Vorschuss, Trump wird gut für die Wirtschaft, umgeschlagen in, nein,
Trump ist nicht gut für die Wirtschaft.
So, das ist die Momentaufnahme aktuell.
Ja, und ich meine, weil es halt auch alles keinen Sinn macht.
Also das Ding ist, jetzt suchen sich natürlich alle andere Märkte. Das ist teilweise...
Und sagen wir mal, führt zu einer Diversifizierung.
Also Kanada wird jetzt sicherlich sehr viel mehr mit UK und mit der EU-Handel betreiben.
Aber auch China ist ja quasi von Zöllen betroffen, aber hat derzeit eher so
eine, wir warten mal ab-Politik und wir kriegen das schon irgendwie anders hin.
Wir wissen schon, wie wir euch bestrafen können in der Zukunft.
Trotzdem, wenn es halt für China teilweise zu teuer wird, und das betrifft jetzt
vor allem die neuen Zölle, die jetzt auch die EU betreffen in Bezug auf Stahl.
Dann werden natürlich die Überkapazitäten, die sie haben, die sie dann nicht
so ohne weiteres in den USA versenken können, die gehen dann natürlich in andere Länder.
Und das betrifft dann wiederum die EU, wo gerade die Stahlindustrie ohnehin
schon eine schwere Zeit hat.
Und das wird natürlich jetzt durch solche Strafzölle nicht einfacher.
Und klar, EU hat ja im letzten Mal schon, als Trump damit anfing,
relativ erfolgreich zurückgeschlagen, indem sie eben sehr spezifisch auf Redneck-Produktkategorien
gegangen sind, so Harley-Davidson und alles, was so dem Republikaner Spaß macht.
Das machen sie sicherlich derzeit auch, muss man mal schauen.
Aber trotzdem, diese Überkapazitäten gerade Chinas, die halt jetzt umgeleitet
werden, die führen schon zu einigen Problemen.
Also vor allem wird das Ganze, droht es eben jetzt auch zu so einer globalen Rezession zu führen.
Also darauf, ich weiß nicht, ob man sich schon darauf einstellen muss,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall etwas,
was sehr wahrscheinlich geworden ist, dass eben die Gesamtweltwirtschaft jetzt
unter diesem Hin und Her extrem leidet,
weil was die Märkte überhaupt nicht mögen, das ist irgendwie Unsicherheit und
mehr Unsicherheit als derzeit entsteht, kann es ja kaum geben.
Das ist tatsächlich das Hauptproblem, nämlich, dass keiner weiß,
worauf er sich einzustellen hat.
Und das ist halt Investitionsgift.
Weil wenn du weißt, okay, die nächsten vier Jahre oder so sind die Steuersätze
jetzt so und so und so, dann kannst du dich irgendwie darauf einstellen.
Aber wenn du einfach nicht weißt, geht es jetzt nach oben, geht es jetzt nach
unten, Bleiben die Zölle, kommen die Zölle, warten die Investoren einfach ab und investieren nicht.
Und deswegen derzeit wohl, was so Analysten, Wallstreet-Analysten angeht,
gehen sie davon aus, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit einer Rezession in den USA
derzeit bei 40 Prozent liegt.
In anderen Worten, Sie wissen auch nicht, ob eine Rezession kommt oder nicht.
Aber man kann generell sagen,
dass sich der Ausblick radikal geändert hat gegenüber zwei oder drei Monaten,
bevor Trump angefangen hat.
Hat man eigentlich ein solides Wachstum für die USA zwischen zwei und drei Prozent
prognostiziert beim Bruttoinlandsprodukt.
Und im Moment geht man jetzt davon aus,
dass es möglicherweise bei minus zwei oder minus drei Prozent landen könnte,
was halt ein Desaster wäre und natürlich,
ja, könnte so eine Rezession katastrophale Auswirkungen auf die öffentlichen Haushalte haben,
heißt, Steuereinnahmen gehen zurück,
Sozialausgaben steigen an, weswegen sie gleichzeitig versuchen,
sowieso Sozialausgaben schon mal zu reduzieren.
Und ich meine, fragt sich jetzt, okay, kann das denn, wissen Sie vielleicht irgendwas mehr?
Sind Sie irgendwie klüger und haben halt irgendeinen Plan? Und.
Wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt, könnte die USA maximal 300 Milliarden Dollar
pro Jahr mit Zöllen einnehmen,
wenn sie ausgehend vom derzeitigen Handelsvolumen und ausgehend davon,
dass das halt nicht zurückgeht und dass man nicht jetzt komplett prohibitive Zölle macht.
Das ist aber, ja, damit lässt sich jetzt Einkommenssteuer oder andere Steuern
nicht wirklich ersetzen.
Oder auch im Vergleich zum US-Haushalt,
das ist irgendwie ein Drittel vom Rüstungshaushalt, was da bei rumkommt.
Und wahrscheinlich werden dann aber die Steuereinnahmen einfach als Folge in
anderen Bereichen zurückgehen.
Also eine Substitution von Steuern durch Zölle, die ja im Grunde genommen sind
Zölle ja auch Steuern auf Einfuhren.
Also es ist eine spezielle Art von Steuer. Und in dem Zusammenhang auch wieder
so ein Wahnsinn, wo man das Gefühl hat.
Leute sind bekloppt geworden, weil Trump sagt ja, die EU erhebt ja einfach Zölle auf unsere Waren.
Zum Beispiel Deutschland erhebt 19% Steuern auf alle Waren, die wir dort hinliefern,
womit sie halt die Mehrwertsteuer meinen.
Ja, etwas völlig anderes ist, weil als Importeur, wenn du das verkaufst,
kriegst du die Mehrwertsteuer halt wieder zurück.
Und es gilt halt für inländische und ausländische Waren.
Aber aus amerikanischer Sicht ist die europäische Mehrwertsteuer aus Trumps
Sicht eine Steuer gegen Amerika.
Also ich meine, auf Basis solcher, ja, solchen Schwachsinns operieren sie gerade.
Und man weiß natürlich auch nie, an welcher Stelle lügen sie besseren Wissens
oder haben nicht wirklich Ahnung.
Und ich glaube, dass in den meisten Fällen sie wirklich keine Ahnung haben.
Dass sie einfach nicht wissen, was sie tun.
An manchen Stellen lügen sie bewusst, aber so an vielen Stellen,
glaube ich, wissen sie es nicht besser.
Das ist natürlich noch tragischer.
So, weil wenn sie denn einfach nur lügen würden dann, na gut, das ist dann einfach nur.
Rationales Verhalten oder rationalisierbares Verhalten aber wenn sie halt auf Basis,
von Nicht-Fakten von Fantasien handeln und darauf ihre Entscheidungen basieren
lassen, das kann zu nichts Gutem führen.
Ja, wie zum Beispiel diese Erzählung mit dem Handelsdefizit.
Das führt ja die ganze Zeit heran und sagt so, ja, ist ja alles so unfair.
Wir haben ja ein riesiges Handelsdefizit mit Europa.
Wir zahlen denen ja viel mehr Geld, als die uns zahlen.
Ja, weil ihr halt konsumiert irgendwie und wir produzieren und ihr wollt ja konsumieren.
Deswegen kauft ihr das ja auch und das ist ja genau eigentlich das,
was euren Reichtum ausmacht.
Also hättet ihr kein Handelsdefizit, dann werdet ihr ja auch nicht mehr so reich
im Vergleich zum Rest der Welt.
Und er beklagt eigentlich, wenn man es mal richtig liest, seinen eigenen Reichtum.
Ja, wie kann es denn sein, dass wir ein Defizit haben?
Naja, weil ihr halt, weil eure Wirtschaft so stark ist und ihr so viel Kohle
habt und euch den ganzen Scheiß leisten könnt und das ist ja quasi das Ergebnis
der letzten 100 Jahre Politik, die ihr gemacht habt, wo ihr gesagt habt,
ja wir beschützen mal hier die Welt,
so wir setzen mit unserem super starken Militär hier so eine Weltordnung ein
und dadurch ist der US-Dollar quasi hier auch die Leitwährung und das Maß aller Dinge.
Und am Ende hat das einfach dazu geführt, dass die Amerikaner sich halt jeden Scheiß leisten können.
Und die wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr darüber nachdenken.
Das ist eine absolute Selbstverständlichkeit ansehen, aber tatsächlich ist das
halt einfach nur so ein Indikator des Reichtums.
Und jetzt wird das sozusagen als Grund für, wir werden ja beschissen.
Genau, ich habe übrigens auch ein Handelsdefizit mit meinem Supermarkt. So, ja, der...
Wirklich? Ja, genau.
Mein Supermarkt kauft viel weniger von mir als ich von meinem Supermarkt.
Allerdings könnte es sein.
Dass... Du solltest Zölle erheben und die Butter für dich 25% teurer machen.
Ja, ja, ja. Oder mehr Flaschenpfand sammeln, um irgendwie...
Und bestimmt haben manche Flaschen von Sammler einen Handelsüberschuss mit ihrem Supermarkt.
Aber dazu gehöre ich definitiv nicht.
Aber dafür hat der Supermarkt wiederum ein Handelsdefizit mit seinen Lieferanten.
Komisch, dass es noch Supermärkte gibt, oder?
Ich habe ein Handelsdefizit, der Supermarkt hat ein Handelsdefizit.
Jeder hat irgendwie ein Handelsdefizit mit irgendjemandem und einen Handelsüberschuss mit jemand anderem.
Naja, also ja, das ist halt einfach eine komische Denke.
Ich meine, am Ende des Tages,
wir reden ja jetzt viel über ungeplante Konsequenzen oder ungewollte Konsequenzen
von Handlungen oder unabsehbare Konsequenzen.
Und ich meine, für die USA könnte es gut gehen mit den Zöllen,
wenn das dazu führt, dass die anderen Währungen unter Druck geraten und damit
der Dollar dann aufgewertet wird und dadurch die Importe billiger werden.
Und am Ende der Verbraucher sagen, die Preise gleich bleiben,
weil der Dollar steigt und damit dann die Amerikaner mehr Geld haben durch die
Steuern und irgendwie keine Probleme.
Das Problem im Moment nur ist, dass mit dem ganzen anderen Chaos und mit dieser
Unkoordiniertheit, der Dollar fällt.
Also der Dollar ist auch wieder hochgegangen mit Trumps Amtsantritt,
hat aber 10% an Wert wiederum verloren in den letzten Wochen.
Was natürlich Importe zusätzlich verteuert.
Auf der anderen Seite wiederum Exporte für die USA billiger macht.
Aber generell die Erfahrung aus der Vergangenheit ist, was jetzt das Handelsdefizit betrifft,
dass Zölle in der Regel Handelsdefizite vergrößert haben.
Warum? So ein bisschen unklar, aber das ist sozusagen historisch,
sind die Zahlen, was passiert ist in dem Moment, wenn man Zölle eingeführt hat,
hat das nicht dazu geführt, dass das Handelsdefizit zurückgegangen ist,
sondern eher umgekehrt.
Ja, insgesamt muss man einfach sagen, dieses ganze Free-Trade-Ding,
das ist ja quasi eigentlich ein Ergebnis der ganzen US-Politik gewesen und dieser
Welthandel hat ja zu diesem Reichtum überhaupt erst beigetragen.
Und wenn halt jetzt alles wieder hinter Zollschranken versinkt,
dann wird halt einfach die gesamte Wirtschaftsleistung darunter leiden.
Ja, also was die Amerikaner nicht verstehen, glaube ich, ist,
wie sehr sie von dieser Weltordnung, die sie installiert haben, profitiert haben.
Vor allem wirtschaftlich.
Und in anderen Worten, sie wissen nicht, was sie haben.
Offensichtlich. Das ist sie nicht klar, was sie haben oder vielen nicht klar,
was sie haben mit dieser Weltordnung.
Und die werden sich noch echt umdrehen, wenn das sich jetzt ändert.
Sie werden sich ganz schön wundern.
Das ist meine Befürchtung.
Ja, jetzt stellt sich natürlich für die meisten aber erstmal die Frage,
okay, wie geht man jetzt mit diesen Sanktionen um?
Also was ist sozusagen die richtige Antwort?
Eine Maßnahme habe ich ja schon erläutert, das was also die EU macht,
ist ja quasi sehr gezielt auf wirtschaftliche Bereiche zu gehen,
mit Regulierungen oder eben auch
mit Zöllen, die eben spezifisch genau die Wirtschaftsbereiche betreffen,
die in Regionen sich abspielen, wo halt mehrheitlich Republikaner gewählt werden.
Also primär so die Red States.
Bestes Beispiel ist ja hier irgendwie Kentucky, was halt so diese Jack Daniels,
wo der ganze Whisky herkommt und so weiter.
Da hat ja Kanada auch schon drauf gezielt und genauso macht das eben auch die EU.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Möglichkeiten, gegen die USA zu antworten.
Ja, und ich denke,
Regulierungen sind ein Ding, die sind im Übrigen auch gerade auch Musk und Trump
gerade ein massives Dorn im Auge.
Nämlich die EU-Regulierung, die besonders US-Unternehmen betrifft.
Nämlich einerseits Wettbewerbsrecht, wo dann immer wieder so Strafen von der
EU-Kommission gegen Google und Apple und so weiter erhoben wurden.
Und ja, da könnte man natürlich nochmal deutlich von Seiten der EU einen drauflegen, nämlich,
dass man speziell Regulierungen sich überlegt, die halt den Einfluss von US-Unternehmen im Zaum halten.
Und gleichzeitig auch für die breite Masse in der EU vielleicht vorteilhaft sind.
Also dass man zum Beispiel beim Right to Repair nochmal eine Runde drauflegt
und zum Beispiel Repairability-Anforderungen für Produkte erhebt.
Und dann entsprechende Anti-Login-Gesetze für Cloud und Social Network,
Dass man halt in der Lage sein muss,
ohne größere Probleme umzuziehen zwischen von einer Cloud in die andere oder.
Von einem Social Network ins andere.
Also dann das Thema offene App-Stores, was ja die EU auch schon angegangen ist,
wo du, glaube ich, sehr skeptisch bist.
Aber ja, dann generell ja Recht auf Reverse Engineering.
Dann im Bereich der Urheber- und Patentgesetzgebung kann man sich auch Dinge überlegen.
Thema KI-Regulierung und dann natürlich,
Investitionsanreize, also Geld abziehen oder eben nicht mehr in den USA investieren und,
Ja, das wären so Dinge, also alles Alternativen zu zöllen, wie man dann, ja, der USA.
Gut, da habe ich jetzt nicht so den Eindruck, dass das jetzt so ein riesiges
wirtschaftliches Problem nach sich ziehen wird, aber so die Staatsaufträge nicht
mehr an US-Clouds zu vergeben, das ergibt sich ja, und da werden wir gleich
eh noch viel drüber reden,
rein aus den neuen Sicherheitsüberlegungen.
Also das ist ja sozusagen gar nichts, was jetzt auf eine rein wirtschaftliche Überlegung geht.
Zumal eben, du hast es ja schon erwähnt, also offene App-Stores und so weiter.
Ich meine, das, was die EU da bisher an Regulierung hinbekommen hat,
das ist ja eigentlich eher ein Schuss in den Fuß gewesen und kratzt jetzt,
sagen wir mal, die großen Unternehmen nicht groß.
Aber solche Kämpfe wie zum Beispiel diese Steuerhinterziehung, die da betrieben wird,
quasi auf Umwegen über Irland mit dieser permanenten Steuerflucht,
die da begangen werden kann, dass quasi ganze Gewinne außerhalb Europas stattfinden
und nicht die EU-Länder von diesen Verkäufen profitieren.
Also wenn iPhones hier tonnenweise verkauft werden, warum sind die Gewinne,
die darauf anfallen, halt keine Steuern in Europa?
Sondern stattdessen findet das irgendwie alles seinen Weg direkt in die USA,
weil wir ja so viel Umgehung haben.
Also das ist so ein bisschen wie mit diesen Zöllen in Kanada,
also die interprovinziellen Zölle, die sie dort haben, die sich quasi nur selber
behindern. Genau solche Sachen könnten sich jetzt auch in Europa lösen.
Dass man mal einfach mal sagt, wir müssen als EU agieren und wir müssen in unserem
Interesse agieren und nicht jeder einzelne Member State der EU darf jetzt hier ein Schlupfloch haben,
um hintenrum den USA quasi die Kohle in den Arsch zu schieben.
Das sind so die Dinge, die sich eigentlich erstmal lösen müssen und das wäre
automatisch auch, da geht es wirklich um nennenswerte Summen.
Sowas wie Reparability-Anforderungen, am Ende,
da reden wir über keinen nennenswerten Summen und ich glaube nicht,
dass das sehr viel bringen würde und mit KI-Regulierung und so weiter, naja.
Da wirst du die Amerikaner nicht vom Weiterentwickeln abhängen.
Hängen, da ruinierst du im Prinzip eher deine eigene Wirtschaft mit.
Aber Investitionen abziehen, das ist sicherlich etwas, ich habe auch schon gehört,
Europa sollte auch darüber nachdenken, jetzt das Gold abzuziehen aus den USA.
Das sind alles so Dinge, die, glaube
ich, die Banken sehr viel schneller sozusagen zur Erweckung bringen.
Jetzt müssen wir aber mal hier auf den Elefanten im Raum kommen,
nämlich die Änderungen in der internationalen Geopolitik ausgelöst durch ein
Treffen von Präsident Zelensky der Ukraine und Trump und Vance und noch so ein
paar anderen Gestalten,
die sich alle im Oval Office zusammengefunden haben.
Eine auf vielen Ebenen ominöse Veranstaltung.
Hintergrund war, Selenskyj ist ja in Gesprächen und Verhandlungen gewesen mit
den USA, den sogenannten Minerals-Deal abzuschließen,
der nach einem ersten etwas schockierenden Aufschlag der US-Delegation nochmal
kräftig anders ausgerichtet wurde.
Darüber gab es dann eine Einigung und Selenskyj ist in die USA gereist,
um dort das unterschreiben zu lassen. Dazu kam es dann nicht.
Stattdessen gab es halt dieses öffentliche Presse-Meeting im Oval Office,
was insofern schon merkwürdig ist, als dass ja normalerweise,
wenn es um solche Unterzeichnungen geht.
Man erstmal das unterzeichnet und dann gibt es so eine Art Pressekonferenz.
Das ist so der normale Modus. Aber bei diesem Treffen lief es anders.
Es gab erst dieses Treffen und danach sollte irgendwie offiziell zumindest da
was unterzeichnet werden.
Und jetzt erzählen wir natürlich etwas, was wahrscheinlich sowieso alle mitbekommen
haben, aber da müssen wir natürlich jetzt mal der Geschichtsschreibung huldigen
und erzählen, was passiert ist.
Also die haben sich alle in diesem Raum versammelt, da waren dann halt Journalisten anwesend.
Handpicked, muss man dazu sagen. Mittlerweile sind ja so Medienunternehmungen
wie Reuters und AP nicht mehr zugelassen im Weißen Haus, weil die ja nicht Golf
von Amerika sagen wollen,
wie Trump das gerne hätte, sondern irgendwie von Golf von Mexiko gesprochen
haben, woraufhin die dann alle ausgeschlossen wurden.
Stattdessen hat sich später rausgestellt, dass unter anderem ein Mitarbeiter
von TASS, also der russischen Nachrichtenagentur, irgendwie vertreten war.
Angeblich dann aber irgendwie abgeführt wurde, obwohl er hatte also gar keine
Lizenzierung da zu sein, war aber dann trotzdem da.
Also so eine merkwürdige Mischung von Reportern und solchen Leuten,
die eigentlich eher so als Blogger durchgehen durften von irgendwelchen rechten Postillen.
Unter anderem der Freund von Marjorie Taylor Greene, Moskau Marjorie,
der auch irgendwie so ein Right-Wing-Blogger ist.
Und der dann den Reigen auch eröffnete in dieser Runde, nachdem es so ein bisschen Geplänkel gab.
Das Ganze dauerte, glaube ich, so 18 Minuten. Und dann so in den letzten fünf
Minuten ging es heiß her.
Dann kam nämlich dieser Typ irgendwie aus der zweiten Reihe und fragte dann
die für die Weltpolitik so wichtige Frage, ob den Selenskyj keinen Anzug hätte.
Ja, zur Erinnerung, Zelensky läuft seit Beginn des Krieges halt immer in Soldatenmontur
rum, um halt einfach klarzumachen, dass ein Land irgendwie im Krieg ist.
Hat übrigens Churchill auch gemacht.
Von Churchill gab es glaube ich auch irgendwie, es steht eine Büste rum.
Trotzdem hat er dann eben das Gespräch so eröffnet. Ja, und überhaupt,
und das wäre ja respektlos und so.
Und man merkte schon, okay, da läuft jetzt irgendwie ein Skript ab, dann kam irgendwie J.D.
Vance und eröffnete das Feuer auf Selensky, indem er dann irgendwie behauptet
hätte, ja, Selensky wäre ja so ein undankbarer Vogel und er hätte sich ja irgendwie nie bedankt.
Hat er natürlich irgendwie 33 Mal nachgewiesenermaßen bei jeder Gelegenheit
in seinen eigenen Ansprachen, im Kongress, in 1000 Interviews und so weiter,
hat er das natürlich selbstverständlich getan.
Aber das waren halt jetzt irgendwie die Talking Points. Trump hat dann auch
noch irgendwie drauf rumgehauen und Zelensky wusste gar nicht so richtig, wie ihm da geschah.
Am Ende war das ein Riesenskandal. Das Ganze wurde irgendwie dann,
die Runde wurde dann irgendwie aufgelöst und es kam dann eben nicht zu dieser Unterzeichnung.
Und stattdessen hat dann Trump in
der Folge auf einmal
komplett umgeschwenkt und hat die Militärhilfe und auch den Informationsfluss
an die Ukraine eingestellt und sich irgendwie stattdessen mit den Russen in
Saudi-Arabien getroffen zu irgendwelchen Friedensverhandlungen,
wo die Ukraine nicht mit dabei war.
Und aus dem Minerals-Deal mit der Ukraine wurde dann bisher erstmal nichts.
Stattdessen stand aber dann auf einmal angeblich ein Angebot von Putin auf der Liste.
Ja, die ganzen Ressourcen in der Ukraine könnte er ja auch von ihm haben und
außerdem wäre ja auch noch in Russland so einiges zu holen und auf einmal ging
irgendwie alles ganz schnell.
Ja, und die Welt stand da mit runtergeklapptem Kiefer und dachte,
Alter, was geht denn hier ab?
Und ich glaube, dieses Treffen wird in die Geschichte eingehen,
weil es im Prinzip für alle Beobachter nur noch diesen finalen Schluss zuließ,
dass das jetzt sozusagen die Aufkündigung der USA,
des Westbündnisses ist.
Weil diese Einreihung in die ganzen Putin-Versteher, das hat dann sozusagen
allem nochmal die Krone aufgesetzt.
Ja und seitdem geht es rund in der internationalen Geopolitik.
Ja, gut. Mittlerweile hat Trump ja wieder einen Schwenk gemacht und die Geheimdienstinformationen
und Militärhilfe fließen jetzt inzwischen wieder.
Ja, so, aber so dieses tatsächlich, dieses temporäre Aussetzen hat einfach für
extrem viel Schaden gesorgt.
So, weil, ja, das einfach das Gefühl ist, entstanden ist oder nicht nur das
Gefühl entstanden ist, aber man kann sich auf die USA nicht mehr verlassen.
So, das denke ich, ist das Hauptproblem.
Und ja, wie sehr jetzt Trump tatsächlich auf Seiten von Putin ist oder nicht,
was offensichtlich ist, dass er schon immer eine Affinität hatte zu Putin und
auch eine gewisse Bewunderung da war.
Das hat er ja nie verhehlt.
Aber Putin umgekehrt, ich glaube nicht, dass Putin ihm raut.
Die Russen trauen ihm natürlich nicht.
Aber jetzt ist es so, dass eben ihm auch der Westen nicht mehr raut.
Und das natürlich, ja, also das hat
eine Kaskade dann von Reaktionen und Überlegungen ausgelöst bis hin zu.
Wir können uns jetzt auf den amerikanischen Nuklearschirm nicht verlassen und
Frankreich dann quasi angeboten hat,
dass sie die nukleare Abschreckung übernehmen werden für andere Länder erst mal.
Dann bei den sogenannten Five Eyes, also es ist ja so eine enge Geheimdienstoperation
zwischen glaube ich das USA, Kanada, UK,
Australien, wen habe ich denn jetzt vergessen?
Neuseeland hast du vergessen.
Neuseeland.
Sozusagen der englischsprachige Raum, der anglosächsische,
Kulturraum.
Ja, und da war dann natürlich jetzt auch,
ich meine, die tauschen halt Geheimdienstinformationen aus untereinander und
da gingen dann sofort auch die Lampen an, wie, okay,
welche von unseren Informationen, die wir jetzt liefern, landen dann möglicherweise jetzt in Russland.
Und diese Befürchtung war jetzt nicht nur bei den Five Eyes und der EU,
sondern auch Saudi-Arabien und Israel waren nicht begeistert davon und haben
halt auch öffentlich Bedenken geäußert,
so was jetzt die Geheimdienstzusammenarbeit mit den USA angeht.
Und ja, das ist natürlich desaströs.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage,
sind wir jetzt in einem Zeitalter einer neuen Weltordnung tatsächlich angekommen?
Und im Moment sieht es tatsächlich massiv so aus, weil mit Vertrauen,
so eine Sache, da reichen halt, wie man gesehen hat,
drei Minuten im Oval Office, um eine Menge an Vertrauen zu zerstören, die es, ja,
wo es Jahrzehnte dauern wird, das wieder zu reparieren, wenn es überhaupt reparabel ist.
Und ja, in allen Bereichen und dann natürlich, ich hatte mir beim letzten Mal
auch schon kurz erwähnt, die Frage,
was bedeutet das für die amerikanische Rüstungsindustrie?
So kann man sich jetzt überhaupt noch darauf verlassen, dass amerikanische Hightech-Waffen
noch funktionieren, wenn die USA der Meinung ist,
wir möchten nicht, dass ihr jetzt eure Waffen für die Verteidigung gegen Russland einsetzt.
Genau, also lassen Sie mal vielleicht erstmal die Reaktionen nochmal so ein
bisschen sammeln und dann können wir nochmal auf die Konsequenzen kommen.
Also das war auf jeden Fall zu spüren, dieser Schock.
Alles, was sich bis dahin an Skepsis aufgestaut hat, glaube ich weltweit,
schon nach der ersten Trump-Präsidentschaft und jetzt natürlich auch im Vorfeld dieses Treffens,
war ja alles schon mal so latent auf der Kippe.
Aber es gab immer so eine Balance zwischen den Doomsayerern,
die sagen, alles ist verloren, wir müssen irgendwie in die eine Richtung abmarschieren
und den Transatlantikern, die sagen so, ja nee, warte mal, das ist alles nicht
so gemein, passt schon irgendwie,
das müssen wir nur irgendwie aussitzen, ja, wir müssen eben nur genug Honig
ums Maul schmieren und wir kriegen das schon irgendwie alles gedeichselt.
Es kann ja nicht sein, dass jetzt hier irgendwie Jahrzehnte der Kooperation
zum Vorteil der USA auf einmal komplett in den Wind gejagt werden.
Nur mit diesem Treffen war dann irgendwie allen klar, okay, dann halt doch besser wohl nicht.
Und ich denke, mittlerweile sind dann also alle Plan B-Zettel aus der Schublade
geholt worden und werden jetzt entsprechend abgearbeitet.
Und nirgendwo merkt man das, glaube ich, so stark wie in Europa.
Ich meine, es hat ja keine...
Kein Tag gedauert und es gab irgendwie ein EU-Nottreffen, bei dem sich irgendwie
alle Führer zusammengefunden haben und dessen Ergebnis war,
okay, alles klar, wir müssen die Remilitarisierung Europas einleiten.
Wenige Tage später gab es dann den entsprechenden Beschluss,
dass bis zu 800 Milliarden Euro, glaube ich.
Jetzt von den einzelnen Mitgliedstaaten investiert werden kann und das wird
eben nicht dem Schuldensystem der EU angerechnet.
Also es war ja quasi jetzt erstmal noch kein unmittelbarer Beschluss einer Militarisierung,
also da wurden jetzt keine Waffen bestellt oder so,
sondern es wurde nur gesagt, wenn ihr jetzt aufrüstet, wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie
Staatsgeld nehmt und das irgendwie in die Rüstung investiert,
dann hat das eben keine Auswirkungen auf irgendwelche EU-Defizitverfahren.
Wir wissen ja, in der EU gibt es diese Regeln, ihr dürft euch nicht zu sehr
verschulden, 3% Hürde, la la la, wurde mehrfach von Einzelnen auch mal gerissen,
auch von Deutschland und so weiter, ja Schwamm drüber und so,
aber im Großen und Ganzen bestehen halt diese Regeln, um einfach ein stabiles
EU- und Eurofinanzsystem zu haben.
Und das wurde im Prinzip jetzt ausgesetzt, wenn es sich um Geld handelt, was in die Rüstung geht.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt Zeitenwende 2.0.
Auf einmal ist klar, okay, wir müssen uns jetzt selber verteidigen.
Die USA haben jetzt durch das Verhalten von Trump im Prinzip den jahrzehntelang
geltenden Konsens mit wir beschützen euch, ihr macht den Rest.
Und der wurde einfach aufgekündigt. Der wurde nicht formal aufgekündigt,
aber im Prinzip haben jetzt alle die Botschaft verstanden.
Und das führt sogar dazu, dass sogar UK und Frankreich und überhaupt die EU
wieder miteinander reden. Und dass es also auf einmal Treffen gibt.
Gut, das ist natürlich auch dadurch beflügelt worden, dass wir es jetzt nicht
mehr mit einer Tory-Regierung zu tun haben.
Aber ich glaube, selbst mit einer Tory-Regierung in UK wäre es jetzt so gekommen.
Und man sieht das auch, wie also selbst Reform UK hier mit Nigel Farage und
so weiter in UK ihre Schwierigkeiten haben, da irgendwie ihre Pro-Putin-Haltung
in irgendeiner Form noch durchzudrücken,
sondern da ist also wirklich alles in heller Aufruhr und wenn sogar schon UK
in heller Aufruhr ist, dann ist es also für uns allerhöchste Zeit.
Ja und das hat natürlich jetzt wirklich Implikationen, du hast es schon angesprochen.
Also vor allem dieser Trust, der spielt sich ja nicht nur auf dieser wirtschaftlichen
Ebene ab, den wir jetzt schon ausreichend diskutiert haben, sondern eben vor
allem auf einer militärischen Ebene.
Die USA, und das ist halt auch wieder so, man fasst sich einfach nur an den
Kopf, wie die USA überhaupt bereit sind, das alles aufzugeben oder ins Risiko zu setzen.
Also allein die Präsenz der USA in Europa, die ganzen militärischen Standorte
sind ja auch eine Garantie für die ganzen wirtschaftlichen Aktivitäten,
haben wir schon jetzt gesagt.
Das ist im Prinzip alles, am meisten hat von der neuen Weltordnung hat immer die USA gesagt.
Profitiert.
Von der alten.
Weltordnung hat die USA profitiert. Von dem, was jetzt hier aufgerufen wird,
kann die USA einfach nicht mehr in dem Maße profitieren.
Und das führt natürlich jetzt auch dazu, dass Europa jetzt sagt,
okay, wir müssen jetzt self-sustained werden.
Also jetzt endlich nach drei Jahren haben sie begriffen, dass Russland eine Bedrohung ist.
Bloß bisher war das halt immer so, ja, wir haben ja die Amerikaner am Rücken,
uns kann ja nichts passieren.
Aber jetzt kriegen alle kalte Füße und merken so, oh oh, jetzt könnten wir auch
in so eine Ukraine-Situation kommen, dass die Russen uns angreifen, was machen wir dann?
Dann schicken wir unsere nicht
vorhandenen Soldaten, die mit dem nicht existenten Panzermaterial dann.
Nicht vorhandenen Flugabwehrsystemen und nicht vorhandenen Aufklärungssystemen
dann irgendwie die bekämpfen oder was?
Also auf einmal ist der Kaiser nackt und alle sehen es und jetzt muss natürlich
auf einmal alles ganz schnell gehen.
Muss man sozusagen sagen, Macron hat es schon immer gesagt, das ist sozusagen
seine Kritik schon vor Jahren gewesen und alle immer so, ja, hier irgendwie.
Schöne Sonntagsrede, aber hast du sie noch alle jetzt hier irgendwie aufrüsten,
das kriegen wir doch bei unseren Bürgern nicht durch und was das überhaupt kostet
und wir wollen uns doch hier irgendwie auf andere Sachen konzentrieren,
wir haben doch die Amerikaner am Rücken. Da müssen wir doch eigentlich nichts machen.
Ja, und Trump hat zwar schon vor Jahren gesagt, wir sollen alle mehr für die Rüstung ausgeben.
Das machen wir dann später irgendwie. Und die einzigen, die halt wirklich mehr
für die Rüstung ausgegeben haben, das war halt im Wesentlichen Polen und Skandinavia ein wenig.
Und ja, jetzt haben wir den Salat. Nur die Auswirkungen für die USA,
die sind natürlich jetzt auch hardcore, weil wie du schon richtig angedeutet
hast und wir haben ja auch glaube ich in der letzten Sendung auch schon über
die Problematik mit der F-35 zum Beispiel gesprochen,
da wurden wir noch korrigiert, ich war mir nicht so sicher, ob Deutschland auch
eine Bestellung offen hat, aber das ist so.
Also auch Deutschland, weg sozusagen F-35 zu bestellen oder ist da schon im Prozess.
Das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, wie weit das ist und wie kündbar das ist.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich kann mir jetzt gar nicht vorstellen,
dass überhaupt noch irgendjemand bereit wäre, F-35 zu bestellen.
Zumindest nicht in der UK-Variante, wo das sozusagen alles auch noch von der
US-Infrastruktur abhängt.
Die einzigen, die halt F-35 fliegen und die nicht von den USA abhängen,
sind die Israelis, weil die waren schon immer schlauer.
Ja, wobei UK auch unabhängiger ist als alle anderen Länder.
Sie haben auch einen Großteil eigene Avionics, aber nicht so viel wie Israel.
Also Israel ist da glaube ich am...
Nochmal einen Schritt weiter.
Nochmal einen Schritt weiter, aber alle anderen Nationen nehmen das Ding wohl
im Wesentlichen komplett mit US-Elektronik und US-Computern und sind halt auf Updates angewiesen.
So, natürlich Ersatzteile.
Ja, genau. Und da haben jetzt natürlich alle Schiss davor. Und auch bei anderen
Technologien hat man das.
Wir haben ja zum Beispiel die auch in der Ukraine sehr erfolgreich eingesetzte
Storm Shadow Marschflugkörper.
Die gibt es ja in einer französischen und einer englischen Variante.
Und ich habe mich schon immer gefragt, was ist denn da eigentlich der Unterschied,
wenn es sich technisch eigentlich um das Gleiche handelt. Und siehe da,
Storm Shadow enthält US-Komponenten und darf halt auch nur mit Einverständnis
der USA entsprechend eingesetzt werden.
Die Skype-Variante der Franzosen hat das nicht.
Die Franzosen, und das ist ja im Prinzip die Politik von De Gaulle gewesen,
die haben sich ja schon immer verabschiedet.
Die waren immer der Meinung, wir klemmen uns hier nicht an die USA und unsere
ganze Militärindustrie, das muss alles unabhängig sein.
Da sind sie ja auch jahrzehntelang für kritisiert worden. Man war ja auch lange Zeit nicht in der NATO.
Das muss man sich auch nochmal vergegenwärtigen. Die Franzosen wollten nicht
in die NATO wegen, ja, nee, mit den Amerikanern und so.
Das haben sie dann zwar irgendwann mal wieder revidiert, aber grundsätzlich
sind halt die Franzosen das vielleicht von den USA am weitesten unabhängige
Land, vor allem eben in militärischer Hinsicht.
Und das zahlt sich jetzt natürlich doppelt aus, Weil es von daher natürlich
auch die einzigen sind, die quasi vollkommen unabhängig von den USA in der Lage
sind, einen nuklearen Schutzschild anzubieten.
Was sie jetzt getan haben, da sind wir jetzt schon angekommen.
Dass also auch Polen darüber nachdenkt, irgendwie Atomwaffen sich zuzulegen etc.
Und das passierte jetzt alles innerhalb von einer Woche. Das war wirklich unglaublich.
Ja, also speziell Polen hat dann richtig einen rausgehauen, hat jetzt angekündigt,
sein Militär von 200.000 auf 500.000 zu vergrößern,
jeden Erwachsenen militärisch auszubilden.
Also quasi eine Volksreserve zu schaffen.
So wie das übrigens Finnland schon immer macht.
Und auch Atomwaffen und andere nicht konventionelle Waffen zu entwickeln,
also zumindest zu prüfen, die entwickeln kann.
Also das war eine ziemlich klare Ansage.
Ja, wenn noch was die Finanzierung angeht, hattest du ja schon erwähnt jetzt,
so einmal, dass jetzt die EU mehr Spielraum schafft für die einzelnen Länder.
Heißt es auch noch in der Überlegung, dass die EU, beziehungsweise nicht nur
in der Überlegung, sondern es sind jetzt irgendwie um die 100 Milliarden jetzt
erst mal, die die EU beschlossen hat,
an Krediten aufzunehmen,
die dann zu günstigeren Bedingungen, aus denen dann Mitgliedsländer ihre Rüstung finanzieren können.
Und ein interessanter Punkt ist jetzt, wie viel finanzieller Spielraum ist eigentlich da.
Und das Interessante ist, dass die UK und Frankreich mittlerweile relativ hoch verschuldet sind,
also ungefähr auf US-Niveau in der Größenordnung, so 120 Prozent vom BP plus
minus 10 Prozent oder so in der Gegend.
Und Deutschland aber wegen dieser dämlichen Schuldenbremse, die uns jetzt quasi
in die Rezession geführt hat,
hatte aber einen Vorteil, dass Deutschland jetzt einfach eine Menge Spielraum
hat, weil Deutschland im Vergleich
zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt im Moment nur halb so viele Schulden hat.
Nämlich ungefähr bei 60 Prozent liegt mittlerweile.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt sagt,
okay, wenn wir jetzt 120 Prozent quasi als unseren Spielraum betrachten,
auf 120 Prozent vom BIP zu gehen,
haben wir ungefähr 2000 Milliarden Kreditspielraum als Deutschland im Moment.
Ja, also zwei Billiarden Euro könnte Deutschland jetzt an Krediten aufnehmen.
Und das ist natürlich gewaltig. Das ist gigantisch.
Ob das passieren wird, wird man sehen. Aber auf jeden Fall, ja, Spielraum ist da.
Und es wird natürlich jetzt abzuwarten bleiben,
wie das jetzt vor dem Hintergrund der in der Verfassung verankerten Schuldenbremse organisiert wird.
So und mit zwei Drittel Mehrheit, die im Moment noch existiert, kann man,
die könnte man sie im Grunde genommen komplett abschaffen oder entsprechende
Ausnahmeregelungen schaffen oder eben,
was man auch tun kann, ist Notstand zu erklären, weil es gibt halt schon die Notstandsklausel.
Aber so einen Notstand kann man halt nicht über zehn Jahre aufrecht erhalten.
Das ist immer nur so ein temporäres Ding.
Und wie wir da jetzt durchkommen, wird man sehen, nachdem sich die Grünen jetzt
quergestellt haben. Die Zeit tickt, aber man wird sehen.
Und der existierende 100-Milliarden-Fonds, der vor drei Jahren geschaffen wurde,
der ist wohl zum größten Teil bereits, also 60, 70 Prozent sind schon weg von
dem Geld. Also da ist nicht mehr so viel drin.
Ja, das heißt, und da ist jetzt dann der Plan,
auch einen neuen Fonds zu schaffen, beziehungsweise soll ein riesiger Fonds geschaffen werden,
wo dann alles Mögliche, also Sozialprogramme und Wirtschaftsförderung finanziert wird.
Und was jetzt die Rüstung angeht, sollen Ausgaben dafür im Prinzip komplett
aus der Schuldenbremse ausgenommen werden.
Das heißt, dass man letztlich sagt, okay, wir haben ein paar hundert Milliarden,
jetzt machen wir für alles andere und bei Rüstung, ja, whatever it takes.
So, dass eigentlich ein guter Ansatz so.
Auch aus Sicht jetzt von Abschreckung und anderem zu sagen, ja,
wir werden jetzt die nächsten zehn Jahre, 20 Jahre, wie auch immer.
Diesen Kurs fahren.
Und das hätte viele Vorteile, wenn man sich jetzt einfach festlegt.
Einmal Investitionssicherheit und auf der anderen Seite dürfte das dann auch
die Abschreckung einfach stärken.
Und vielleicht, es gibt ja noch Hoffnung, vielleicht können wir das ja alles
vermeiden, weil sollte jetzt nicht hier der Eindruck entstehen,
dass wir jetzt begeistert sind oder das toll finden,
wenn jetzt unglaublich viel Geld für Rüstung ausgegeben wird,
statt für Schulen und Bildung und Soziales.
Nur aus der anderen Sicht, wenn tatsächlich ein Krieg ausbricht,
dann ist der um eine Größenordnung teurer als das, was wir jetzt tun und was wir gesehen haben, ist,
dass der Krieg in der Ukraine ja ein Versagen von Abschreckung war.
Der wäre vermeidbar gewesen, wenn man vorher nur einfach klare Ansagen gemacht
hätte und das hat man nicht.
Und Russland dachte halt, es wird ein Spaziergang und hat auch nicht mit,
glaube ich, mit so einer harten Reaktion des Westens gerechnet,
weil beim ersten Mal haben sie ja auch nicht so richtig hart reagiert.
Und ja, also sieht man leider,
dass Abschreckung die einzig sichere Methode ist oder die sicherste Methode ist,
um Krieg zu vermeiden oder allgemeine Abrüstung.
Aber allgemein abrüsten kann man auch nur, wenn man selber was zum Abrüsten hat.
Wenn man jetzt an die Russen rantritt und sagt, okay,
ihr rüstet jetzt, ihr gebt jetzt, weiß ich nicht,
2000 Panzer ab und wir 200, weil wir haben nur noch so wenig.
Prozentual sozusagen.
Ja, so wird es nicht funktionieren. Und dasselbe ist halt mit atomarer Abrüstung.
Ich hatte schon seit ewigen Zeiten schon überlegt, wie kann man denn irgendwie
als Europäer oder als Deutscher, wie könnte Deutschland denn jetzt die nukleare
Abrüstung voranbringen und leider nur durch Androhung,
sich nuklear zu bewaffnen.
Das ist halt irgendwie das bekloppte Ding, dass man die Nuklearwaffen von anderen
nur wegkriegt, offenbar, wenn man selber welche hat.
Und wenn nicht, das ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen tragisch.
Tragisch wird das aber auf jeden Fall auch für die USA. Auch wieder so ein Punkt,
wo man sich hier nur an den Kopf fassen kann, Weil was das natürlich jetzt alles
ausgelöst hat, das wird dann für die USA doppelt und dreifach teuer.
Denn mit Waffen ist es so, das ist teuer, die zu entwickeln und insbesondere
dieser ganze Hightech, auf dem der Westen sitzt, ist nochmal extra teuer.
Wenn man jetzt mal das Beispiel dieser F-35 nimmt.
Die F-35 ist für die USA in den letzten Jahren immer billiger geworden,
weil es so viele Länder gab, die sie gekauft haben.
Und dadurch ist irgendwie der Preis, glaube ich, so auf 25 Prozent,
ich weiß jetzt die genauen Zahlen nicht, aber signifikant gesenkt worden.
Also er hat sich fast halbiert irgendwie von.
Ich glaube, ein Viertel, das habe ich gehört, aber egal.
Ja, also es waren irgendwie ursprünglich mal schwierig diese Rechnungen mit,
weil Investitionen, also es waren mal irgendwie zwischen 120 und 160 Millionen
pro Stück und inzwischen sind sie irgendwie auf 80 Millionen runter.
Sagen wir mal die Hälfte.
Und das macht natürlich eine Menge aus, wenn man sozusagen den eigenen Rüstungsbestand
dann auffrischen muss oder erweitern möchte.
Wenn aber jetzt diese ganzen Bestellungen wegfallen, dann wird es eben sozusagen
für die USA teurer, auch nur ihren eigenen Bedarf abzudenken.
So ist es eigentlich mit allen großen Produzenten. Wir hatten ja auch schon
darüber geredet, dass das ja auch eine Auswirkung auf Russland ist,
deren Rüstungsexporte derzeit einfach bei Null sind.
Und wahrscheinlich auch noch eine ganze Weile bei Null bleiben wird,
weil sie auf der einen Seite nichts produzieren können,
weil sie alles gerade selber verheizen, aber auf der anderen Seite auch gerade
keine Hightech-Forschung groß machen können, eben weil diese ganzen Bestellungen auch ausbleiben.
Also sie haben gar keine Kohle, um das irgendwie zu investieren.
Das wird ihnen noch lange nachhängen. Sie können zwar jetzt sehr viel produzieren,
aber Hightech produzieren sie auf keinen Fall.
Aber für die USA wird es richtig teuer.
Ja, ein anderes Problem ist noch eine kleine Anekdote,
von der ich gehört habe, was so die US-Rüstungsbeschaffung angeht,
die da nochmal einen interessanten Blick drauf wirft.
Und die USA hatte ja in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren Probleme mit der Beschaffung neuer Schiffe.
Da gab es halt dieses Literate Combat Ship, was halt vielfaches von dem gekostet hat.
Und ewige Verzögerungen und dann auch mit der Zumwaldklasse und so.
Deswegen hatten sie sich jetzt überlegt,
Als sie jetzt neue Fregatten brauchten, sagt man, okay, bei kleinen Schiffen
ist Europa einfach marktführend.
Das heißt, sie haben dann sich entschieden, für die neuen Fregatten,
die eine von Italien, von Finkantieri,
zuzunehmen, ein erfolgreiches Off-the-Shell-Regatte.
Und ja, damit das billiger wird, damit sie halt solche Probleme vermeiden.
So mittlerweile haben sie aber so viele Anforderungen und Designänderungen in
den letzten Jahren auf diese Off-the-Shell-Regatte,
dass nur noch 80 Prozent anders sind, dass nur noch 20 Prozent Gleichteile sind
und sie sind immer noch nicht fertig mit der Spezifikation.
Das ist also ein bisschen wie beim BER, kannst du sagen,
da haben wir ständig neue Änderungen, neue Änderungen, neue Änderungen und haben
jetzt die Hälfte der Kohle schon rausgehauen und noch nicht mit einem einzigen Schiff angefangen.
Also selbst wenn sie von der Stange irgendwie Rüstungskram kaufen, funktioniert es nicht.
Und ein anderes Problem ist doch, in dem Zusammenhang hat das US-Militär riesige
Probleme mit Ride-to-Repair.
Weil mittlerweile diese neuen Hightech-Schiffe, also früher war es so,
so ein Schiff hast du halt ein komplettes Manual.
Wo alles drin ist, wo du im Prinzip unterwegs so ziemlich alles warten und reparieren kannst.
Mittlerweile ist es so, dass diese Rüstungsfirmen halt ihren Kram da installieren,
ohne das zu dokumentieren oder denen die Tools so mitzugeben.
Und jetzt war es zum Beispiel so, dass bei letzten, bei den Literal Combat Chips,
die haben halt eine Tankanzeige, wie
voll der Tank ist und die muss halt rekalibriert werden einmal im Jahr.
Aber das können die Matrosen nicht, also auf dem Schiff können die das halt nicht selber machen.
Das heißt, da fliegen dann Experten von Lockheed um die Welt nach Australien
und nach Singapur und wo immer die Schiffe gerade sind,
um dann die Tankanzeige zu kalibrieren, was halt irrsinnig viel Geld kostet.
Das heißt, das amerikanische Militär ist mittlerweile auch in vielen Dingen
einfach verkrustet und ineffizient und extrem teuer.
Ich meine, es ist so ein Merkmal, glaube ich, generell von Rüstung, dass...
Dass das teuer ist, aber man sollte nicht denken, dass die Amerikaner jetzt
irgendwie, ja, das ist doch alles.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob man das unter Right to Repair zusammenfassen sollte,
aber die Abhängigkeit eben von digitalen Systemen im Wesentlichen,
die es ja meistens sind und damit eben direkt von den Herstellern,
dass das sozusagen alles so as a service geliefert wird, das ist natürlich ein absolutes Problem.
Aber bleiben wir mal bei diesen geopolitischen Auswirkungen,
die wir jetzt sozusagen haben durch diesen Moment, durch diesen Oval Office
Moment, der führte einfach dazu, dass jetzt irgendwie sich alles neu aufstellt.
Europa löst sich mental quasi auf. Es gibt auch schon Diskussionen darüber,
neben der NATO quasi so eine europäische Verteidigungsorganisation zu gründen.
Auch die gesamte Rüstungsbeschaffungsmaßnahme wird quasi teilweise durch die
EU durchgeführt werden.
Also man kauft sozusagen Zeug jetzt als Europa ein und hat dadurch natürlich
ein ganz anderes Handelsvolumen.
Also auch hier wieder so ein Effekt mit Schockwirkung führt dazu,
dass man endlich mal diese nationalen Grenzen aufbricht, so wie wir das in Kanada
mit den Zöllen hatten, haben wir das ja im Prinzip innerhalb von Europa auch.
27 EU, 27 verschiedene Umsatzsteuerregelungen, 27 verschiedene Gesetzesgebungen,
die zwar hier und da harmonisiert sind durch irgendwelche EU-Richtlinien,
die aber dann doch immer noch mal wieder so ein bisschen anders sind.
Grundverordnung gibt es natürlich für manche Dinge auch, wo also wirklich dasselbe
Recht und Gesetz gilt, aber am Ende des Tages haben wir so viele Begriffe.
Jetzt nicht unbedingt Handelsbarrieren, aber so mentale und regulative Barrieren
und gerade wenn es um nationale Rüstung geht und welche Unternehmen produzieren
denn jetzt hier überhaupt irgendwas,
haben wir so viele nationale Gegeninteressen,
die schon immer dazu geführt haben, dass es einfach nicht vorangeht.
Ein gutes Beispiel in dem Zusammenhang und das ist natürlich jetzt auch sehr
wichtig, gerade wenn wir jetzt auch noch auf so Auswirkungen wie Starlink und
Abhängigkeit von amerikanischer Infrastruktur im Weltraum nachdenken.
Auch die Aussetzung dieses Informationsflusses bedeutete ja auch,
die Ukraine bekam keinen Zugriff mehr auf die Sattel.
Also temporär ist jetzt wieder zurückgesetzt worden, aber es hat ja einmal gereicht,
dass es einmal stattgefunden hat. Das führt jetzt sozusagen zu diesem Sinneswandel.
Also die Ukraine bekam dann auch keine Daten mehr von Maxa, von so einem privaten
amerikanischen Satellitenunternehmen, die halt diese High-Res-Fotos liefern,
die also sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig war,
um kurzfristig so Truppenverlagerungen und so etwas zu erkennen.
Und hier merkt natürlich jetzt Europa auch, oh wow, in diesem ganzen Aufklärungsbereich,
wir haben zwar auch unsere Satelliten oben, aber wir haben nicht ansatzweise so etwas wie Starlink.
Das Beste, was wir haben und das kommt natürlich jetzt auch zum Einsatz,
ist dieses OneWeb-System.
OneWeb ist ja auch ein LEO-System, also ein Low-Earth-Orbit-System,
ähnlich wie Starlink. Es funktioniert anders.
Das sind dann so Satelliten im Polar-Orbit und es sind nicht so viele Satelliten
und es hat auch nicht diese selbe,
es ist nicht so gut ausgebaut, wie Starlink funktioniert, nicht so gut wie Starlink.
Ist vor allem auch ein reines Business-System.
Das heißt, du kannst als Privatkunde jetzt nicht ein One-Web-Terminal kaufen,
wie jetzt mit Starlink und das irgendwie auf deinen Wohnwagen ballern und dann
hast du irgendwie ein Netz oder stellst dir irgendwie einen Garten und hast irgendwie
ein Netz, wo die Telekom keine Glasfaser hinliefern will, weil wir uns da auch
permanent im Weg stehen.
Und jetzt ist natürlich auch auf einmal eine Frage, können wir auch noch auf
die Satellitendelivery durch SpaceX zählen?
Oder überhaupt auf die Amerikaner?
Müssen wir jetzt sozusagen auch dort unsere eigene Weltraumdelivery sichern?
Und das ist ja eine Debatte, die geht seit Jahrzehnten und wir hatten jetzt so viele Fälle, dass.
Europa auf SpaceX ausweichen muss und die halt mittlerweile einmal die Woche
eine Rakete starten. Muss man ja auch mal sehen.
Also Elon Musk hat es da mit seinem Unternehmen geschafft, wirklich mit Abstand
das effizienteste Weltraumunternehmen an den Start zu bekommen.
So sehr man den Typen jetzt hassen möchte, muss man halt sehen,
also inwiefern das jetzt sein persönliches Verdienst ist, sei jetzt mal da hingenommen,
aber trotz alledem ist vollkommen klar,
SpaceX ist derzeit einfach das potenteste Weltraumunternehmen auf diesem Planeten
und zwar nicht ein bisschen, sondern mit riesigem Abstand. Und was macht Europa?
Europa hat sich jahrzehntelang in so einem Dauerbattle zwischen den Franzosen
und den Deutschen im Wesentlichen festgefahren, als es darum ging,
dieses Ariane-System zu erneuern.
Vielleicht mal so zur Erläuterung, das ist vielleicht auch jedem nicht so klar.
Also wir haben ja quasi die ESA und die ESA ist so das Äquivalent zur NASA.
Also spezifisch auf Weltraummissionen ausgerichtet.
Die ESA ist quasi ein europäisches System. Es ist kein EU-System,
es ist ein europäisches System, ist auch sehr international,
hat auch die Kanadier in gewisser Hinsicht mit drin, die Japaner,
es wird sehr viel kooperiert.
Generell ist der europäische Weltraum-Exploration-Ansatz ja sehr kooperativ.
Wir haben bis vor kurzem auch noch mit den Russen zusammengearbeitet,
bis auf die Chinesen sind wir eigentlich mit allen irgendwie gut da.
Und die ESA ist eigentlich nicht schlecht. Die ESA kann eine ganze Menge,
könnte auch noch sehr viel mehr, hat aber nicht die Mittel.
Es wird nicht sehr viel Geld bereitgestellt für die ESA, also nicht in einem nennenswerten Maße.
Trotz alledem nimmt die ESA auch wichtige Funktionen wahr.
Also die ganze Weltraum, Erdbeobachtung, da ist die ESA führend.
Und natürlich gibt es auch eine diverse Militärtechnik, die halt irgendwie von
den Raketen hochgebracht wird. Und was haben wir denn da?
Naja, also erstens, wir haben den besten Weltraumbahnhof von der Geolokation eigentlich der Welt.
Ja, also französisch Guyana ist am nächsten dran am Äquator,
was quasi für so normale Orbits einfach die ideale Voraussetzung ist,
weil du quasi an der Stelle, wo die Erde am dickbauchigsten ist,
am meisten die Erdrotation mit nutzen kannst, um Raketen ins All zu schicken.
Das ist also auf jeden Fall schon mal super.
Da ist auch eine ganze Menge Platz. Ich war ja mal da, es ist unglaublich riesig, dieses Areal.
Und naja, bis vor kurzem gab es dort halt drei verschiedene Raketensysteme, die dort am Start waren.
Nämlich das Ariane 5 Launch System, dann die Vega, das sind diese kleineren
Raketen, die aus Italien kommen und dann gab es die Soyuz, also die Kooperation mit den Russen.
Die Russen haben auf dem europäischen Startplatz Raketen gestartet zusammen
mit den Europäern. Das ist natürlich seit dem Ukraine-Krieg alles vorbei.
Das heißt, da gab es nur noch zwei. Ariane 5 ist aber jetzt irgendwie end of
life. und jetzt gab es den ersten Start der Ariane 6.
Es hat ewig gedauert, diese Ariane 6 zu entwickeln und durch dieses Hickhack
zwischen den Franzosen und den Deutschen ist es halt wieder so eine Kompromisslösung
gewesen und man hat so viel Zeit und Energie verschwendet und am Ende hat man zwar eine Rakete,
die so ein, zwei Features hat, die jetzt auch, sagen wir mal,
SpaceX nicht haben, Nämlich eine Stufe, die sozusagen neu gezündet werden kann
und damit kannst du irgendwie effizienter nach oben deinen Treibstoff nutzen.
Und das ist auch für komplexe Orbits ganz toll.
Nur...
SpaceX kann irgendwie seine Raketen mittlerweile wieder landen lassen,
also zumindest die Hauptstufe wieder landen lassen und spart sich dadurch natürlich
auch Unmengen an Geld und dadurch, dass sie halt auch solche unglaublichen Durchläufer haben,
also quasi in der Mitte halt jede Woche irgendwie einen Raketenstart machen,
wird ja schon gar nicht mehr darüber berichtet,
dass sie starten, weil die starten einfach die ganze Zeit. Das ist ja wie am
Hauptbahnhof irgendwie.
Und dadurch, dass sie einfach mittlerweile Raketenstufen irgendwie 20 Mal schon
wiederverwendet haben und dadurch, dass sie so viele Starts haben,
haben die einfach eine Economy of Scale mittlerweile erreicht,
wo die Europäer einfach nicht im Ansatz da sind.
Das war natürlich alles super teuer, aber wodurch wurde das finanziert?
Das wurde dadurch finanziert. Also SpaceX gibt es einfach nur,
weil der Staat, die USA, zugesagt hat, macht ihr mal irgendwie euer Development.
Wir garantieren euch hier so und so viele Starts von unseren Spionage- und was
weiß ich, Militärsatelliten.
Die müssen irgendwie alle ins All und damit habt ihr sozusagen auch eure Starts
irgendwie schon mal in Sack und Tüten.
Und so etwas hat halt in Europa nicht stattgefunden,
sondern stattdessen wird halt sehr viel an anderen Startplätzen gestartet und
dann eben nicht mit der Ariane gestartet, die auch nicht für alle Satelliten
geeignet ist, insbesondere nicht die neue Ariane 6, die halt so extrem groß ist.
Die kann zwar sehr viel hochbringen, aber die kriegst du halt auch nicht so oft gestartet.
Und wie viele Starts haben wir dann so? Naja, vier im Jahr oder fünf vielleicht,
wenn man es jetzt mal hochtreibt.
Das ist so die Größenordnung der Produktion, die wir jetzt erreichen mit diesen Raketen.
Während, wie gesagt, die SpaceX und die Amerikaner damit sozusagen quasi jede
Woche irgendwas hochballern und dadurch natürlich einen ganz anderen Level erreichen.
Und damit war es natürlich dann auch möglich, sowas wie Starlink zu machen.
Und auch OneWeb, was jetzt quasi das europäische Alternativsystem ist,
was mittlerweile von den Franzosen, von Eutelsat, gekauft wurde und damit Gott
sei Dank in französischer Hand ist,
was sich jetzt als sehr positiv herausstellt, weil man es dadurch jetzt auch
den Ukrainern zur Verfügung stellen kann.
Auch die launchen ihre Satelliten mit SpaceX. Das ist einfach vollkommen irre.
Und ich erwarte, dass wir also auch in diesem Raumfahrtbereich demnächst einen
Wandel erleben werden. Und das ist auch...
Höchste Zeit, dass Europa sich
darauf besinnt, auch in dem Space-Bereich endlich mal wieder zuzulegen.
Weil bisher ist das einfach gemanagter Stillstand.
Ja, konkret was das Budget angeht.
Also NASA-Budget von 20,4 Milliarden US-Dollar.
ESA-Budget 7,4 Milliarden US-Dollar.
Also ungefähr 30 Prozent ist das ESA-Budget vom NASA-Budget.
Was aber, ja, nur der Rahmen ist das eigentliche Geld jetzt,
wie du richtig sagtest, kommt dann aus Aufträgen, Dinge hochzubringen.
Und insofern wäre wahrscheinlich sowohl ESA-Budget erhöhen, als auch so etwas zu machen.
Na, Launcher vor allem. Also Ariane ist was. Ich weiß nicht,
das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich in diesem ESA-Budget so nicht mit drin.
Also Ariane ist ja sozusagen der eigentliche Launcher. Die NASA-Launcher selber auch nicht mehr.
Also die hatten zwar Projekte, aber das kommt auch alles nicht so richtig voran.
Also sie haben noch eine große Rakete für ein paar Missionen,
aber das Allermeiste, was halt kommerziell so abgefeuert wird,
das läuft halt mittlerweile über SpaceX.
Und ich gucke gerade mal, Ja, Ariane Space macht irgendwie 1,25 Milliarden Umsatz.
Die 150 Mitarbeiter.
Das ist aber eigentlich nichts. Also in dem Segment müsste sehr viel mehr möglich sein.
Und ja, was wir brauchen, ist da einfach eine konsequente Entwicklung.
Das heißt, man muss sagen, okay, jetzt hier auf Basis, ich weiß jetzt nicht,
welche Pläne in den Schubladen sind und wie man vor allem das Problem dieser
Wiederverwendbarkeit jetzt machen will. Es ist nicht so, dass Europa dazu nicht
in der Lage wäre, sowas ingenieursmäßig auch zu leisten.
Es ist einfach nur so, dass dieser ganze Apparat einfach zu träge ist.
Es dauert viel zu lange, bis da irgendwelche Beschlüsse gefasst werden und vor
allem verhungern diese ganzen Prozesse in diesem ganzen innereuropäischen Hickhack,
speziell eben zwischen den Deutschen und den Franzosen, die halt einfach den größten Anteil haben.
Das ist ja so eine Aufteilung.
Die Franzosen sind immer die Launcher-Stellen und die Deutschen liefern eher
so die Technik für die zweite und die Payload-Stufe.
Das ist so ein bisschen die innere Aufteilung.
Naja, man muss da einfach flexibler werden und ich erwarte, dass da auch jetzt
die ESA deutlich klarer mal auftritt und sagt so Leute, wenn das jetzt hier
nochmal was werden soll mit der europäischen Unabhängigkeit,
auch im militärischen Bereich,
dann müssen wir jetzt hier aber irgendwie auch mal langsamer was tun.
Weil es ist ja klar, wir brauchen jetzt irgendwie auch diese Facilities der
Aufklärung, weil wenn die Amerikaner jederzeit halt sagen können,
so ja nö, unsere Erkenntnisse, die teilen wir jetzt nicht mehr mit euch,
weil es passt uns jetzt gerade mal nicht in den Kram, was ihr mit den Russen
macht, dann stehen wir halt doof da.
Und du kannst halt einfach ohne
Space-Aufklärung heutzutage einfach kein militärisches System mehr machen.
Ja, übrigens bedauerlich ist auch noch, dass Ariane Space bis 2017 Marktführer
für kommerzielle Starts war.
Ja, die Ariane 5 war das zuverlässigste und erfolgreichste Launcher-System überhaupt.
Aber man kam halt mit der Ariane 6 nicht in die Spur und hat das quasi eigentlich
am langen Abend verhungern lassen.
Und jetzt haben wir den Salat, jetzt haben wir quasi überhaupt gar keine Starts
mehr. Und das ist einfach absurd.
Genau, und SpaceX hat jetzt, wir sitzen ja gerade bei Ariane Space,
irgendwie eine Milliarde oder so.
SpaceX macht jetzt 13 Milliarden Umsatz und hat 13.000 Mitarbeiter statt 400 von Ariane Space.
Also das ist, ja.
Absurd.
Ja, da hat jemand, da haben wir wirklich, ja, dropped the ball.
Total geschlafen.
Someone dropped the ball. Ja.
Naja, jetzt ist natürlich auch die Frage, die sich alle stellen,
bei all diesen ganzen Anstrengungen, können wir eigentlich diskutieren,
schaffen, sozusagen. Kann sich Europa ohne die USA, also komplett ohne die USA
überhaupt verteidigen?
Ja. Und das ist auch die Antwort.
Aber Ja oder Ja, aber?
Ich glaube, man kann sagen, uneingeschränkt das mit Ja beantworten.
Also gegenwärtig jedenfalls, weil ganz offensichtlich hat Russland ja schon
ein Problem mit der Ukraine allein.
Aber wenn jetzt, was halt so ein Szenario ist, wenn
jetzt Europa und die USA die Ukraine einfach komplett im Stich lassen würden
oder die Ukraine dann wieder unter russischer Vorherrschaft landet, ist die Befürchtung,
dass dann die Ukrainer mehr oder weniger gezwungen werden oder einverleibt werden
in die russische Armee und dann losgeschickt werden gegen Polen oder gegen.
Das Baltikum.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Szenario und das würde dann zwar nicht morgen passieren,
aber das ist eher sowas, was dann nach ein paar Jahren einfach drohen würde.
Aber grundsätzlich.
Ja, wenn man sich allein nur die Zahlen anschaut, jetzt an Bevölkerung, also Europa,
wenn man jetzt die EU plus die europäischen NATO-Länder plus Ukraine plus Türkei nimmt,
dann kommt man, muss man sagen, auf 650 Millionen Europäer.
So willst du.
Und es ist einfach kein normaler Zustand,
dass irgendwie 650 Millionen Europäer, 330 Millionen Amerikaner fragen sich
vor 145 Millionen Russen zu verteidigen.
Also das allein ist irgendwie schon mal eigentlich ein bisschen irre,
aber das ist letztlich Ergebnis von amerikanischer Politik, die einfach auch nicht wollten,
dass Europa zu stark und zu selbstständig wird.
Das war ganz klar im amerikanischen Interesse, Europa jetzt nicht als möglicherweise
zu sehr als starken eigenen geopolitischen Spieler zu haben.
Das heißt, sie haben schon auch versucht, zu viel europäische Einheit zu verhindern.
So.
Und das heißt, Europa ist eigentlich so ein bisschen ein schlafender Riese.
Hat gegenüber den USA demografische Nachteile und,
Und das europäische Rüstungsbudget liegt nur bei 50 bis 75 Prozent des amerikanischen, je nachdem,
ob man die reinen Zahlen nimmt oder sozusagen Kaufkraft angepasst.
Und insofern liegt Europa jetzt gar nicht finanziell so weit zurück,
ist aber komplett zersplittert und eben ineffizient.
Und ja, man hat es sich einfach auch ein bisschen bequem gemacht, muss man sagen.
Aber das war letztlich auch grundsätzlich im Sinne der USA.
Und ja, wenn es aber definitiv, wenn es nötig ist und Europa sich einig ist,
Europa hat die Technologie,
Europa hat die Bevölkerung, Europa hat die Wirtschaft. so.
Und wenn das jetzt so ist, wie es ist, dann kriegt Europa das auch hin.
Wenn man sich auch anguckt, allein nur bei den reinen Zahlen,
dann jetzt Kampfpanzern und Flugzeugen und was halt sonst noch so da ist,
hat Europa ohne die Amerikaner einfach jetzt schon mehr als die Russen und in
technologisch höherer Qualität.
Aber das Problem im Moment ist, dass sich die USA quasi in die gesamte europäische
Verteidigung einfach ja,
hineingewachsen sind oder hineingeben haben und einfach wichtige strukturelle Aufgaben wahrnehmen.
Das heißt, die sind die einzigen, die eine große Tankerflotte haben,
zum Beispiel und bei anderen eben Assets ja,
haben sie zwar nicht ein komplettes Monopol, aber,
da ist Europa weit, weit hinterher, einschließlich eben vor allem so Führungsstrukturen
und Koordination und so weiter und generell Mobilität und Logistik.
So, da hat Europa hat gar nicht die.
Die Mobilitätsreserven, um jetzt, was weiß ich, Truppen schnell aus Spanien
irgendwie ins Baltikum zu verlegen oder so.
Das ist halt das Problem und das europäische Militär ist eben auch nicht darauf
ausgerichtet, jetzt global irgendwie, ja,
Macht zu projizieren.
Das ist nur sehr, sehr beschränkt. Allein, ich meine, die USA haben halt 13 Flugzeugträger,
wo jeder ungefähr das Äquivalent einer nationalen Luftwaffe darstellt,
die sie halt verschieben können.
Und Europa ist halt, was Flugzeugträger angeht,
es gibt welche, ich glaube insgesamt sieben Stück oder so,
aber der Großteil davon sind halt eher so Hubschrauberträger oder die können
halt nur Vertical Take-Off and Landing machen und also sind deutlich kleiner
als die amerikanischen Flugzeugträger beispielsweise.
Das andere ist ja bei AVEX-Flugzeugen, also sozusagen elektronische Aufklärung,
ist Europa auch wichtig.
Ja, unterausgestattet. Plus natürlich generell Abhängigkeit von vielen US-Waffensystemen.
So Patriot vorneweg und so, was jetzt gerade auch so ein bisschen zum Problem wird.
Aber grundsätzlich, würde ich sagen, ist da nichts so, was Europa nicht innerhalb
von wenigen Jahren selbst an den Start bringen kann.
Und teilweise in einzelnen Bereichen sind die europäischen Waffensysteme sogar
besser als das, was die Amerikaner haben. Ja.
Bevor wir da gleich wieder in den Kommentaren korrigiert werden,
ich habe kurz mal nachgeschlagen, also die USA haben derzeit elf richtige Flugzeugträger und neun,
Hubschrauberträger, also nicht ganz so falsch,
zwei, die irgendwie noch im Bau sind oder auf Kiel gelegt sind,
einer bei Hubschraubern und auch die Die Franzosen haben einen richtigen,
drei Hubschrauberträger.
UK haben zwei Flugzeugträger und einen Hubschrauberträger.
Und dann gibt es nur noch einen Hubschrauberträger in Spanien.
Und die Türkei hat einen richtigen Flugzeugträger und einen Hubschrauberträger.
Da kann man jetzt diskutieren, ob das dazugehört oder nicht.
Ist also auf jeden Fall ein NATO-Land. Also so richtig üppig ist es halt nicht.
Aber größenordnungsmäßig, ja, okay.
Aber du hast recht, die Logistik ist vor allem das Ding. Und das ist,
glaube ich, auch, das muss man sich immer wieder klar machen,
Militär heißt vor allem Logistik.
Also es geht nicht nur so um Waffen und Kampfkraft und Soldaten,
sondern man muss vor allem mobil sein, man muss es irgendwie auch versorgen können.
Und das ist halt die besondere Rolle eigentlich der USA in der Welt, des US-Militärs ist,
die sind in der Lage, innerhalb kürzester Zeit mehr oder weniger an jedem Ort
dieses Planetens innerhalb überschaubarer Zeit Truppen zusammenzuziehen und
diese dort auch über längere Zeit zu versorgen.
Also so ein Krieg wie in Afghanistan, Irak, so falsch die waren.
Waren halt möglich, weil sie eben überall diese Standorte haben,
weil sie ein riesiges Netz an Versorgungsstrecken haben und eingespielter Logistik
und eine riesige Flotte von Transportflugzeugen,
die in der Lage sind, Truppen und die Versorgung dieser Truppen jederzeit zu garantieren.
Und das ist halt so ein Apparat, der permanent im Betrieb ist.
Und die einzigen Länder, die außer den USA überhaupt über so ein globales Netz
von Standorten verfügen,
was auch nur so ansatzweise ein internationales Agieren, also an anderen Orten
erlaubt oder eine schnelle Verlegung erlaubt, sind halt Frankreich und Großbritannien.
Okay.
Aber die USA haben letzten Zahlen, ich hatte größtenordnungsmäßig 500 Militärbasen.
Um die Welt herum waren mal mehr.
Aber ja, plus 1000 Basen in der USA. Jetzt zu Schätzungen, kann es ja mal nachgucken.
Also ja, USA ist einfach militärisch, ich meine, USA war bisher für die Hälfte
der globalen Rüstung verantwortlich.
Das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen zurückgegangen.
Aber so die USA war 50% des globalen Militärs so an also in Dollar gemessen jetzt,
und ja hast du die Zahlen für die amerikanischen Militärbasen schnell.
Bin ich da auch nicht.
... ...
Liste von Militärbasen der Vereinigten Staaten im Ausland. So, was haben wir da?
So, nach eigenen Angaben 2008,
761 militärische Einrichtungen aller Teilstreitkräfte Army, Air Force,
Navy, Marine Corps im Ausland.
Das sind 14% von 5.429 insgesamt.
Also 761 militärische Standorte weltweit.
Je nachdem wie man die zählt. Also es ist auf jeden Fall Irrsinn.
Da kommt kein Land, auch nur in den Rand. 40 davon in Deutschland übrigens.
Zwei davon sollen jetzt irgendwie zugemacht werden.
Ja. Naja, egal.
Also ist ja auch nicht die Frage, sondern die Frage ist, was kann Europa tun,
um sich selber zu verteidigen und die Antwort ist im Prinzip so rein von den Möglichkeiten schon,
nur dass es halt jetzt Not tut, eben die ganze Rüstungsindustrie auch wieder
auf so einen industriellen,
Takt zu bringen, um das eben auch entsprechend in kurzer Zeit zu machen,
weil derzeit sind es halt alles mehr so Manufakturen und nicht wirklich große Produzenten.
Aber das ist ja etwas, was jetzt schon seit längerem angestoßen wurde.
Durch diesen Krieg haben sich also jetzt verschiedenste, zumindest in Deutschland
die Unternehmen halt auch entsprechend eingestellt und das Rheinmetall ist am
Ausbauen der Kapazitäten,
baut neue Munitionsfabriken und das eben sowohl in Deutschland als auch in vielen
anderen Ländern. Und Rheinmetall hat auch, glaube ich,
irgendwie Standorte, glaube ich, in 120 Ländern. Also es ist schon irgendwie auch krass.
Die sind eigentlich nur, ich glaube, Nummer 4 oder 5 was so Rüstung.
Also das 4. oder 5. größte Rüstungsunternehmen der Welt.
Ja gut, aber es ist ja auch nicht das Einzige. Naja, also auf jeden Fall,
geht schon und muss jetzt sozusagen passieren und wird natürlich dann aber auch,
selbe Logik, auch billiger werden.
Also in dem Moment, wo jetzt ganz Europa aufrüstet und auch noch die Europäische
Union als Einzelaufkäufer oder Garant und so weiter oder als Kreditnehmer,
agiert, wird es natürlich dann auch schnell billiger, während es halt für die
USA jetzt theoretisch teurer wird, weil man kann davon ausgehen,
dass diese Aufrüstung, diese europäische Aufrüstung wird wahrscheinlich eine nahezu,
ausschließlich europäische Geschichte werden.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendjemand noch in den USA jetzt irgendwas kaufen wird.
Also irgendwelche kleinen Sachen, die nicht abhängig machen,
wie Munition oder so, ja, okay, vielleicht, aber sicherlich keine großen Systeme.
Eine Ausnahme dürfte Südkorea sein, die sicherlich als vertrauenswürdig gelten.
Das wird sich zeigen.
Die aber auch mittlerweile zu einem großen Waffenproduzenten.
Ja, die sind riesig, aber bei denen muss man zumindest keine Angst haben,
dass sie jetzt irgendwie morgen,
den Einsatz der eigenen Waffen untersagen.
Zumal die ja auch sehr freigiebig sind, dann mit Lizenzen sagen,
also Polen hat ja sehr viel bestellt und,
üblicherweise sind so große Rüstungsdeals beinhalten oft eine Komponente,
wo dann Teile im Importland gefertigt werden, also wo man dann auch Kapazitäten
aufbaut und in Polen bauen die Koreaner dann auch jetzt neue Fabriken auf.
Aber ja, ja.
So rein budgetmäßig, wenn jetzt Europa auf 2,5 Prozent vom BIP hochgeht,
von der Zeit im Schnitt 1,9, 1,8 oder so ist, glaube ich, der europäische Schnitt aktuell.
Aber selbst der Sprung von 2 auf 2,5 Prozent würde Europa bereits kaufkraftbereinigt
mit den USA gleichziehen, was das Rüstungsbudget angeht.
Und Trump hat ja jetzt in üblicher Manier gesagt, die Europäer sollen jetzt 5% ausgeben.
Wenn Europäer 5% vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt in Rüstung investieren würden,
wären das irgendwie 1800 Milliarden und hätte dann einen Rüstungshaushalt,
der größer ist als der von den USA und China zusammen.
Ja, was halt absoluter Irrsinn wäre wahrscheinlich.
Und Russland, ja gut. Also mit anderen Worten,
so da ist Potenzial, also wenn Europa sich entscheiden würde,
quasi auf kalter Kriegsniveau hochzugehen, wo Deutschland lag damals bei vier
bis fünf Prozent vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt so in den 70er Jahren.
Wenn wir auf dieses Level wieder hochgehen würden, so als ganz Europa,
hätten wir mehr Streitkräfte, hätten wir, sozusagen hätte Europa, ja.
Mehr Streitkräfte als die, oder, na gut, die Chinesen haben halt viele Leute,
aber es ist jetzt bereits so, dass selbst ohne Türkei und die Ukraine,
die Europäer mehr Truppen haben als die USA jetzt bereits,
ja, wenn du noch die Ukraine und die Türkei mit dazu zählst,
zum Beispiel, dann ist ja Europa
jetzt schon ungefähr die doppelte Truppenstärke in Soldaten wie die USA.
Also nur mal so die Dimensionen klar zu machen.
Also ist nicht gut Europa wirklich zu wecken, weil Europa einfach mal 2000 Jahre
Historie in permanentem Krieg führen hat.
Ja, das habt ihr jetzt davon. Deutschland bewaffnet sich jetzt irgendwie.
Das wollten wir da eigentlich die ganze Zeit verhindern.
Das habt ihr jetzt irgendwie davon.
Übrigens habe ich mal geguckt, wie viele Länder, wie viel Zeit denn so Länder
typischerweise mit Krieg verbringen.
Und bei allen größeren Ländern, ihr habt das mal für die letzten,
500 Jahre oder so, beziehungsweise für die USA kann man nur 200 Jahre zurückgehen
oder 250 Jahre zurückgehen.
Aber Größenordnung sind sozusagen 20 Prozent.
Also von jedem Jahrhundert verbringen die meisten Länder ungefähr 20 Jahre im Krieg.
Wie viele haben wir denn jetzt schon weg? Achso, das ist ja ein neues Jahr,
aber wann fangen wir dann an wieder zu zählen?
Also 20 Jahre hatten wir im letzten Jahrhundert auf jeden Fall voll Ja, mal gucken,
Da wir ja eigentlich ein Podcast sind, der sich mit der Ukraine beschäftigt,
sollten wir vielleicht dieses Verteidigungsthema auch noch kurz auf die Ukraine
ausdehnen weil darum geht es ja eigentlich.
Denn ein Teil dieser ganzen Bewaffnungen, über die jetzt diskutiert wird,
ist ja eh klar, wird vor allem,
oder vielleicht die falsche Formulierung, aber ein Großteil der Investitionen,
die jetzt getätigt werden in militärische Ausrüstung,
die wird ja dann auch sofort zum Einsatz kommen müssen, denn wenn die USA jetzt
die Ukraine verhungern lassen wollen, muss Europa einspringen.
Das heißt, viel dieser Rüstungsproduktion, die jetzt gestartet werden wird,
zwangsläufig, wird ja auch mehr oder weniger direkt in die Ukraine gehen.
Und da stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was können derzeit denn an Unterstützung
auch wirklich geleistet werden, beziehungsweise was wird derzeit geleistet werden.
Was wir ja schon haben, ist, dass einerseits Länder wie Dänemark vor allem,
Skandinavia ja schon seit einiger Zeit umgesattelt haben auf,
wir geben jetzt das ganze Geld nicht unbedingt jetzt dafür aus,
dass wir selber irgendwas produzieren oder dass wir aus unserem Bestand etwas
in die Ukraine umleiten,
sondern wir investieren direkt in die Produktion in der Ukraine,
weil die ist da sehr viel effizienter und sehr viel schneller und vor allem
sehr viel billiger zu machen.
Das ist sicherlich eine Winning-Strategie. Und ich kann mir auch sehr gut vorstellen,
dass man von vielen dieser Gelder quasi in der Ukraine bestellt und es dann
auch gleich dort zum Einsatz bringt.
Dann hatten wir schon erwähnt, die Franzosen können natürlich jetzt eine große
Rolle spielen, nicht nur im logistischen Bereich und was Militärtechnik betrifft,
die liefern ja auch schon so einiges,
sondern eben auch durch die Bereitstellung von OneWeb.
Das kennen nicht so viele, eben weil es eben ein System ist,
was nicht so im Public Mind ist, weil es halt kein Consumer Device ist.
Aber das wäre natürlich mittelfristig auf jeden Fall etwas, was den drohenden
Verlust von Starlink ausgleichen könnte.
Das wird also an der Stelle auf jeden Fall sehr viel mehr Interesse erhalten.
Und dann stellt sich natürlich vor allem die Frage, wird jetzt die im März geführte Regierung,
die uns jetzt droht, dann wirklich das Versprechen wahr machen und solche Lieferungen
wie zum Beispiel Taurus-Systeme dann wirklich an die Ukraine wahr machen.
Ja, ich meine, das Taurus-Thema ist interessant,
ist jetzt hochgekommen und wieder natürlich genau dadurch und das wäre schon
ein deutlicher Gewinn für die Ukraine,
weil im Gegensatz auch zu den Sculp,
und Stormshadows die,
hat Taurus ungefähr die doppelte Reichweite. Das heißt, sie können halt Ziele
in bis zu 500 Kilometer Entfernung bekämpfen.
Und ja, das ist einfach eine krasse Waffe, die speziell dafür gebaut ist,
dass gehärtete Strukturen,
also quasi Flugzeuge, die in Bunkern oder Scheltern stehen oder unterirdische
Kommandozentralen und Bunker anzugreifen oder auch Brückenpfeiler.
So als Beispiel.
Ja, ja. Und das Ding hat auch gewisse Stealth-Charakteristiken,
fliegt aber so generell dann wohl in 30 Metern Höhe ungefähr bis zum Ziel und
hat eben diesen Doppelsprengkopf,
Und der,
wo erstmal vorne ein kleiner Sprengkopf dran ist,
der halt ein Loch macht für dann den großen Sprengkopf, der dann so ungefähr 400 Kilo wiegt oder so.
Also ein ziemlich dickes Ding, der dann unter der Erde oder im Shelter explodiert.
Also es ist schon eine ziemlich fiese Waffe, mit dem faktisch die Ukraine nochmal
die russischen Flugzeuge oder die russischen Basen auf noch mehr Abstand bringen könnte.
Und jetzt nach der Attackums-Lieferung, die ja so bis 300 Kilometer ungefähr
reichen, haben die Russen sehr viel außerhalb der Reichweite verlegt.
Und Taurus würde bedeuten, dass sie nochmal 100 bis 200 Kilometer weiter weg
dann ihre Flugzeuge parken müssten, so konkret gesagt.
Und ja, in Deutschland, also es wurden insgesamt 600 Stück, glaube ich, davon gebaut.
Und so die Bundeswehr könnte wohl 100 Stück davon ungefähr an die Ukraine abgeben,
ohne sich selbst zu entblößen.
Aber das Problem, das hat man ja auch schon mal erwähnt, ist.
Für die Missionsplanung brauchst du halt ein detailliertes Höhenmodell.
Und das wird dann sozusagen, Teile des Höhenmodells werden dann in die Rakete
reingeladen plus andere Dinge und so.
Also es ist, in anderen Worten, vor jedem Abschuss sitzt da jemand ein,
zwei Tage und plant die Mission und lädt die Daten in diesen Marschflugkörper rein.
Und entweder man überlässt den Ukrainern dann auch dieses System und schult sie darauf,
was wohl so ausgeht, dass sie so sechs bis neun Monate brauchen würden,
bis sie halt selber komplett Missionen planen könnten.
Oder man schickt halt dann Deutsche oder die Missionsplanung wird dann von Deutschland aus gemacht.
So was natürlich ein bisschen heikel ist, so politisch.
Einfach, weil man eigentlich sagen kann, okay, das waren jetzt die Ukrainer,
die das Ding abgeschossen haben.
Sondern faktisch wäre das, dass dann deutsche Soldaten damit befasst wären,
die Missionsplanung zu machen.
Ja, also man könnte, das werden wir sehen. Also ich habe da noch so ein bisschen
meine Zweifel, aber warum eigentlich nicht so?
Und ich meine, warum können sie nur 100 abgeben? Also warum können sie nicht
mehr als diese 600 abgeben?
Also die würden ja sowieso dazu verwendet werden, russisches Material zu vernichten.
Da kannst du das ja auch jetzt machen.
Ja, ja, ja. Ich meine, die andere Sache ist, das ist halt ein deutsch-schwedisches
Gemeinschaftsprojekt.
Also Saab steckt da auch noch mit drin. Das heißt, Deutschland ist nicht das einzige Land.
So, deswegen die Bundeswehr hat, glaube ich, 300 bestellt und irgendwie ein
bisschen was davon verbraucht.
Die Bundeswehr alleine hat 600 bestellt.
600, okay, bestellt. Aber die sind, glaube ich, sind die auch schon alle geliefert.
Ich glaube, sie wollen jetzt aber auch...
Ist auch alles geliefert worden, 2010. Ja.
So, das heißt, ein paar davon sind halt auch bei Übungen verwendet worden.
Und so, die 100 war jedenfalls die Zahl, die ich gehört habe,
wo die Bundeswehr sagen würde, die können wir entbehren.
Wo die Bundeswehr selber sagt, so, das hätten wir, mehr würden wir nicht,
aber das ist auch, sagen wir mal, der Stand von vor einem Jahr in dieser ganzen
Diskussion, wo Scholz halt gesagt hat, wir geben mal hier gar nichts weg.
Und ich bin jetzt mal sehr gespannt, wie sich das jetzt ohne Scholz in der neuen
sogenannten Großen Koalition entwickeln wird.
Nicht, dass ich darauf setze, dass das März ein Mann des Wortes ist.
Ich meine, er hat ja im Prinzip jetzt schon vor Antritt seiner Regierung alle
seine Versprechen gebrochen.
Zum Glück muss man sagen, aber naja, so viel kannst du da halt drauf geben,
was er irgendwie gesagt hat.
Aber am Ende ist natürlich Deutschland jetzt im Zugzwang.
Und wenn sie irgendwie auch nur halbwegs irgendeine Glaubwürdigkeit herstellen
wollen und irgendein Vertrauen herstellen wollen, auch der Ukraine gegenüber,
muss es ja nun zwangsläufig auch ein signifikantes Signal geben der geänderten
Grundhaltung, sowohl was die neue Regierung als auch die neue Situation betrifft.
Und da kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nichts anderes vorstellen als eine Änderung
dieser Taurus-Politik und wenn es nur ein politisches Signal ist. Ich meine, ob diese.
Waffen am Ende einen großen Unterschied machen, werden wir sehen.
Das sind ja, wie du schon gesagt hast, sind ja auch eher bunkerbrechende Systeme,
die mehr oder weniger ein spezifisches, klar umfasstes, lokal begrenztes Ziel gut erreichen können.
Die Attack-Cams, die vielleicht jetzt nicht, oder die Storm Shadows.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz mal nachdenken, bei den Attack-Cams war es ja so,
dass die auch durch ihre Cluster-Munition so effizient waren.
Gerade was jetzt den Angriff von Flugzeugen betrifft.
Das heißt, wenn du die auf einen Landeplatz losschickst, wo irgendwie zehn Maschinen
stehen und du schaffst es halt irgendwie eine Explosion eines einzelnen Cluster,
Sprengkörpers in der Nähe dieser Maschinen zu machen, dann sind die halt alle im Eimer.
Weil Flugzeuge und Löcher und so weiter passt irgendwie gar nicht gut.
Da musst du sie nicht komplett zerstören, um sie außer Betrieb zu nehmen.
Aber wenn du sozusagen nur einen Springsatz hast, der sozusagen lokal begrenzt
ist, da aber super effizient, dann eignet es sich eben mehr eben,
wie du gesagt hast, auch für Bunker oder eben Brücken.
Ob es da Brücken gibt, die um 500 Kilometer Reichweite sind? Naja.
Ja, also es jetzt ein bisschen aus dem Fokus geraten, so die Kertschbrücke und
hat so ein bisschen auch an strategischer Bedeutung verloren, weil,
sich die Russen nicht trauen, dass,
Viele Dinge darüber, also zum Beispiel LKW oder so, seit sie schlechte Erfahrungen
mit explodierenden LKW gemacht haben,
schicken sie die alle per Fähre rüber und die Schienenstrecke ist auch nach
wie vor geschwächt und können keine vollbeladenen Züge rüberschicken und so.
Aber haben ja jetzt auch dort die Landbrücke.
Da haben sie ja neue Zugverbindungen gebaut, die Russen, Mariupol, die gegen...
Ja gut, aber die Fähren sind alle im Eimer und würde halt die Brücke komplett
wegfallen, wäre das natürlich auch rein moralisch auch ein riesiger Boost.
Also das ist natürlich schon so ein bisschen der Inbegriff und das wäre eine
riesige Niederlage für Putin.
Also ich denke, wenn die Ukrainer sich selbst in der Lage säen,
mit dem, was ihnen zur Verfügung gestellt wird, diese Brücke weiter zu dismanteln,
dann würden sie das auch tun.
Selbst wenn es jetzt nicht die Wende im Krieg ist, aber es ist halt alles hilft
und insofern könnte das schon auch helfen.
Na gut, wir müssen uns jetzt nicht so sehr an diesen Taurus-Dingern festbeißen.
Wichtiger ist natürlich auch eine Wende im Bereich der anderen Waffensysteme,
wo die USA bisher etwas liefern, was Europa nicht hat.
Und das ist natürlich vor allem in der Luftverteidigung das Problem der Patriot-Systeme.
Würde also jetzt die USA auch die Lieferung von Patriot-Raketen oder überhaupt
nur den Betrieb dieser Patriot-Systeme auch noch unterbinden,
dann sieht es halt richtig schlimm aus.
Und das ist ja so, also as we speak jetzt hier zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
sieht es so aus, als ob die Ukraine jetzt Kurs aufgegeben hat.
Also die Russen haben auch noch dieses kurze Fenster, wo die Ukrainer keine
Informationen bekommen haben und wo irgendwie die Waffenlieferungen eingestellt
wurden, was jetzt nicht entscheidend war.
Aber diese Informationsembargo haben die Russen sofort genutzt und haben eine
Großoffensive gestartet und das hat jetzt dazu geführt, dass die Ukraine Kursk
verlassen muss oder schon weitgehend verlassen hat.
Also ich glaube, Sucha ist schon gefallen.
Also man sieht, wie schnell so etwas eine Auswirkung haben kann.
Würden die Patriots-Systeme nicht funktionieren?
Dann hätte das natürlich erhebliche Auswirkungen, weil die Patriots-Systeme
sind derzeit die einzigen Systeme, die wirklich einen halbwegs zuverlässigen
Schutz gegen überschallballistische Raketen liefern.
Das heißt, das Schlimmste, was so die Russen losschicken können,
da wären also dann die Hauptstädte nicht mehr gut geschützt,
Kiew vor allem, aber auch andere große Regionen und vor allem auch der ganze Rüstungsbereich.
Der Ukrainer. Von dem die Russen sicherlich wissen, wo er ist,
aber wo sie nicht ohne weiteres rankommen.
Teilweise auch alles unterirdisch und so weiter.
Aber das ist halt etwas, wo Europa auf jeden Fall jetzt schnell nachlegen muss.
Und hier frage ich mich, ob es vielleicht möglich ist, mit den Israelis noch
eine Einigung zu erzielen.
Ja, also die einzige Alternative, die so ein bisschen an Patriot rankommt,
ist ja das hauptsächlich unter französischer Federführung, das SEMTI-System,
was so von der Reichweite her hat kleine und große Raketen und hat sogar teilweise
größere Reichweite als Patriot mit den großen Aster-Raketen.
Und das Problem ist nur, dass die eben gegen ballistische Raketen nicht so gut
funktionieren, auch wegen einer unglaublichen Versionsvielfalt bei der Software und so.
Da weiß man nie genau.
Allerdings gab es halt gerade vorgestern einen Erfolg, wo die Ukraine bestätigt hat,
dass sie ein russisches Kampfflugzeug abgeschossen haben,
jetzt gerade vorgestern mit SEMT, irgendeine SU-Fraktion.
Irgendwas.
Okay, so schick.
Aber auf der anderen Seite gab
es daneben auch Meldungen, dass auch da die Raketen jetzt knapp werden.
Aber es gibt halt da diese, die SEM-T benutzt entweder die Aster-15 oder die
Aster-30 Und die Asta 15 ist eher so nahbereich bis 30 Kilometer.
Und die Asta 30, ja, wohl bis zu 300 Kilometer, obwohl offiziell nur 120 Kilometer.
Aber sie hat tendenziell wohl eine etwas höhere Reichweite als Patriot, die Asta.
30. Und ja, Problem ist natürlich auch, dass,
ich glaube, es vier Jahre dauert, bis so ein Aster-System im Moment,
also sie bauen nur alle vier Jahre ein neues Aster-System sozusagen und Paketen sind eben auch,
auch knapp.
Das wird sich jetzt wohl auch ändern, nehme ich mal an.
Ja, gehe ich auch mal.
Von aus. Ansonsten, gut, was ich jetzt auch gehört habe, da hatten wir auch
vor zwei Jahren mal drüber gesprochen, über die deutschen Smart-Granaten.
Das sind diese Artillerie-Granaten, die die dann über dem Ziel aufgehen.
Also Suchzündermunition nennt sich das.
Wo du sie im Prinzip ungefähr in die Nähe über das Ziel bringst und dann in
dem Fall von Smart kommen da zwei Suchzünder raus,
die gucken, was gibt es für interessante Ziele und dann dieses Ziel, die Ziele ansteuern.
Und die sind wohl recht erfolgreich in der Ukraine jetzt zum Einsatz gekommen.
Also da habe ich so Interview mit einer Panzerhaubitze 2000-Besatzung gehört,
die eben davon berichtet,
wie sie die eingesetzt haben.
Und dass das gut funktioniert.
Also gut zu wissen, dass unser Hightech, deutsches Hightech-Spielzeug tatsächlich
zu funktionieren scheint unter realen Bedingungen.
Und generell sind die Ukrainer auch super happy mit dem Marder.
Sie haben jetzt ja haufenweise Marder-IFVs, also Infantry Fighting Vehicles.
Der Marder kann halt irgendwie hinten, hat eine Klappe, kann halt sechs Infantriesoldaten besitzen.
Hinten raufladen, Drei-Mann-Besatzung, hat eine 20-Millimeter-Kanone und eine
Milan und hat aber wohl einen recht guten Panzerschutz.
Also das Ding wiegt irgendwie mittlerweile 30 Tonnen, weil im Laufe der Zeit
man irgendwie nochmal drei weitere Panzerschichten draufgepackt hat.
Ursprünglich lag es bei 17, 18 Tonnen oder so.
Und die Neueren haben dann halt nochmal 12 Tonnen mehr Panzerung gekriegt.
Und die waren halt wirklich begeistert davon,
weil die Drohnen tatsächlich, weil die Drohnen fest sind.
Also diese FPV-Drohnen können die Marder-Panzerung wohl nicht durchschlagen.
So entstehen zwar Schäden und so, aber ja, gab es halt Berichte,
dass sie halt auf einer Fahrt von fünf Drohnen getroffen worden sind und einfach, ja,
abgebreiter gefahren sind. Ja, ja.
Also das scheint zu funktionieren, ist aber auch, ich weiß nicht,
ich bin glaube ich in den 60er Jahren entwickelt, das Ding, aber scheint auch zu funktionieren.
Und die Panzerhaubitze 2000, mittlerweile sind sie auch super happy mit,
nachdem Anfangsjahr es hieß, empfindliche deutsche Hightech und so, aber...
Das läuft gut. Und dann hat jetzt, glaube ich, RCH-155, also diese radgestützte Artillerie,
schon angefangen an die Ukraine zu liefern.
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube...
Ja, ja, die ersten sind geliefert worden und das ist vor allem sozusagen überhaupt
der erste Einsatz dieser Systeme.
Also das hatten wir, glaube ich, auch schon erwähnt, dass es quasi so ein selbstfahrendes
Artilleriegeschütz mit der Besonderheit, dass es halt das erste Artilleriesystem
ist, was in der Fahrt schießen kann.
Das heißt, die haben halt die Logik so eingebaut, dass sie sagen,
okay, da müsste jetzt die Kanone hinzeigen, damit wir in die richtige Richtung
schießen und das können sie sozusagen in Realtime während der Fahrt machen.
Das heißt, die poltern irgendwie da über den Acker und wenn dann die Kanone
in dem Moment genau an der richtigen Stelle ist, dann ballern sie halt irgendwie los.
Das heißt, sie kommen nie so richtig zum Stehen oder müssen nicht unbedingt
zum Stehen kommen und sind von daher natürlich so für Counter-Battery-Fire nicht
so ein Ziel. Davon gibt es aber noch nicht so viele.
Was aber wohl auch, glaube ich, in der Ukraine produziert werden soll,
sind die Nachfolger von diesen Maran, die Lynx-Schützenpanzer.
Die sind wohl für Tests schon mal geliefert worden und die Serienproduktion
beginnt dann auch in der Ukraine.
Und tatsächlich die Lynx ist auch noch im Wettbewerb für eine Ausschreibung
in den USA als Infantry Fighting Vehicle für die US Army.
Das wird wohl nix.
Oder naja, nur mit so as a service irgendwie. Da müssen die Amerikaner mal die
Deutschen fragen, wenn sie mit denen im Wochenende fahren wollen. Mal schauen.
Ja.
Okay. Soviel zur Militärtechnik.
Ich denke, da können wir auch später nochmal in die Details gehen.
Ja, also vielleicht abschließend sagen, so zur aktuellen Situation in der Ukraine.
Ich hatte mir halt auch nochmal angeguckt von Perun,
der hat halt, sagen auch, zu der Frage, wie sieht es denn jetzt mit der Ukraine
aus, wenn die Amerikaner die Waffenlieferungen abschneiden?
Und wie.
Wie hat sich der Krieg in den letzten Monaten entwickelt?
Und er hat dann interessante Statistiken gemacht, nämlich wie viel Kampfpanzer
und wie viele Soldaten die Russen pro Quadratkilometer verloren haben,
also pro eroberten Quadratkilometer.
Das war im November, Dezember haben sie relativ zu ihren Verlusten Fortschritte gemacht,
aber in den letzten zwei Monaten ist das wieder zurückgegangen.
Also in anderen Worten, die Frage war, geht den Russen die Luft aus?
Und Indikatoren dafür sind eben da.
Also sie machen halt im Vergleich zu ihren Verlusten wieder nur noch halb so
viele Fortschritte oder Landgewinn,
also bis Februar jedenfalls.
Gucken wir mal, wie das jetzt im März aussehen wird. aber die.
Verluste sind groß.
Die Verluste sind riesig und sagt er hat sie dann auch die sagen,
Die Rechnung aufgemacht, wie lange denn eine Schnecke brauchen würde,
die nicht schläft, die sich so im Schneckentempo von der Front bis an die polnische
Grenze durch die Ukraine bewegt.
Und ja, diese Schnecke würde halt diese Strecke in ein paar Wochen zurücklegen.
Ja,
Schnecken sind auf jeden Fall ganz gut unterwegs, ja.
Ja, während bei dem Tempo, was die Russen vorlegen, also ist quasi wörtlich
deutlich langsamer als Schneckentempo.
Ja, was man vielleicht noch kurz nachreichen sollte, ist, dass es ja jetzt auch
die Diskussion gibt um die Unterstützung konkret im Land selber.
Also wir erinnern uns, zu Beginn des Krieges gab es ja Proteste von Ukrainern
in ganz Europa mit dem Aufruf Clear the Skies oder Protect the Skies,
ich weiß nicht ganz genau.
Ich glaube, Clear the Skies war so ein bisschen das Mantra.
Und die Forderung, dass auch Europa oder die USA, also alle Verbündeten,
mit ihrer eigenen Luftwaffe quasi den Himmel über der Ukraine schützen sollen.
Und naja, haben wir gesehen, was daraus geworden ist.
In den letzten drei Jahren halt gar nichts, weil sie irgendwie alle Schiss hatten,
beziehungsweise dadurch halt immer dieses Argument kam, naja,
wenn wir da rumfliegen, dann müssen wir halt auch die Russen abschießen. Das geht ja gar nicht.
Naja, jetzt sind wir halt in der aktuellen Situation und jetzt gibt es aber
wieder diese Diskussion,
angeführt durch die Franzosen, aber nicht nur durch die Franzosen,
sondern es gibt verschiedene Länder, die sich da schon vorgetastet haben.
Das heißt, es gibt in zunehmendem Maße die Überlegung, ob man nicht so etwas durchführen sollte.
Das natürlich nicht an der Frontlinie, sondern quasi im westlichen Hinterland der Ukraine.
Und das würde ja auch gut zu diesen Überlegungen der Militärproduktion und dem
Schutz der Militärproduktion passen, wenn man also quasi den Schutz,
also die Luftabwehr, Raketenabwehr übernehmen würde und generell auch den westlichen
Bereich der Ukraine mit so einer multinationalen Luftwaffentruppe absichern würde.
Dann würde das ja dann eben auch für die Ukraine einfacher werden,
sich eben auf die eigentlichen Frontbereiche zu konzentrieren.
Das ist also definitiv etwas, was in dieser ganzen Debatte der militärischen
Unterstützung jetzt auch zunehmendem Maße auf Gegenliebe stößt.
Ich bin auch ein bisschen skeptisch, dass es dabei zukommen wird,
aber ich würde das jetzt auch mal nicht ausschließen wollen.
Ja, ansonsten doch eins müssen wir noch erwähnen, Nämlich den massiven Luftschlag
gegen Moskau vorgestern, glaube ich,
hat der stattgefunden, wo die Ukraine wohl zwischen 300 und 400 Drohnen auf Moskau abgefeuert hat.
Und es ist unklar, wie viele davon durchgekommen sind.
Also Russland hat jetzt nicht gesagt, wie viele durchgekommen sind,
sondern nur behauptet, sie hätten über 300 Drohnen abgeschossen.
Aber ich habe irgendwie vier verschiedene Einschläge gesehen in Moskau,
die so video-dokumentiert waren.
Ja, also da ist was passiert und die Ukraine hat auch angekündigt,
jetzt ihre Drohnenproduktion nicht FPV-Drohnen oder Kurzstreckendrohnen,
sondern die Dinger, die halt dann Hunderte oder bis über 1000 Kilometer fliegen können.
Die Produktion in diesem Jahr auf 30.000 Stück zu steigern.
Und ein paar tausend ballistische Raketen selber zu bauen.
Das heißt, da wird sich Russland wahrscheinlich auch warm anziehen müssen,
wenn das passiert, weil das ist dann wahrscheinlich eine Produktionssteigerung
Faktor 10 gegenüber dem Vorjahr.
Das heißt, wenn das alles stimmt und zutrifft,
so wird halt die Ukraine einfach Russland massiv aus der Ferne angreifen,
einschließlich Moskau.
Genau, das zeichnet sich ja schon länger ab. Und derzeit ist es auch so,
generell muss man dieser ganze Zeit,
den die Öffentlichkeit derzeit auf diesen Konflikt hat und man sieht halt immer
so, ja okay, Russland dringt vor und macht Landgewinne nicht viel,
ja, wir hatten den Schneckenvergleich eben schon, aber findet halt statt und
jetzt haben sie sich irgendwie auch noch aus Kurs zurückgedrängt,
ja, das ist irgendwie das, was da stattfindet.
Aber auf der anderen Seite fügt die Ukraine auf allen anderen Wegen den Russen
erhebliche Verluste zu.
Also nicht nur, dass sie irgendwie so viele Fahrzeuge von ihnen zerstören und
dass quasi die Russen nur noch mit Meatwaves kämpfen.
Wir hatten ja schon mehrfach darauf hingewiesen, dass sie quasi im Schwarzen
Meer komplett verloren haben, die Russen.
Also sie haben sich ja vollständig zurückgezogen.
Und im Luftraum ist es halt so, okay, da haben die Russen auch viele Raketen,
viele Drohnen, diese Schahett-Drohnen.
Aber mittlerweile antworten halt die Ukrainer in zunehmendem Maße mit gleichen Mitteln.
Die haben jetzt also auch so Schahett-ähnliche Drohnen gebaut.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich die Produktion, von der du da sprichst,
zum Teil. Dazu eben diese ballistischen Raketen.
Das kann ja die Ukrainer im Prinzip auch. Die waren schon immer irgendwie gut in diesem Bereich.
Und grundsätzlich ist es so, an der Front machen diese FPV-Drohnen,
also FPV ist ja First-Person-View,
also sozusagen Kamera-ausgerüstete Drohnen, die halt entweder kamikazemäßig
direkt irgendwo reinfliegen oder eben Granaten abwerfen.
Machen 80 Prozent der Kills aus. Also das ist sozusagen die Hauptwaffe,
mit der die Ukraine derzeit die Russen auf Distanz hält, ist etwas,
was die Ukrainer komplett im eigenen Land produzieren.
Es ist also möglich, die Russen zurückzuhalten mit den Fähigkeiten,
die die Ukraine selber hat,
wenn man sie nur entsprechend finanziell unterstützt, beziehungsweise für die
Produktionsorte dann auch gegebenenfalls noch so eine Luftverteidigung mitbietet.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob wir das beim letzten Mal schon erwähnt hatten,
das akustische Ortungssystem für Drohnen, was die Ukrainer jetzt an den Start gebracht haben.
Das scheint wohl auch so eine interessante Innovation zu sein,
wo sie im Prinzip im ganzen Land Mikrofone verteilt haben,
die am Internet hängen und wo sie dann aufgrund der Geräusche,
die die Dinger machen, weil die sind halt recht laut,
weil sie die Dinger ohne Radar tracken können.
Ist eigentlich nichts Neues. Das ist eigentlich schon vor zwei Jahren schon
mal News gewesen, dass so etwas entwickelt wird.
Aber mittlerweile ist es ihnen wohl gelungen, das nicht nur punktuell zum Einsatz
zu bringen, sondern eben so ein richtig flächendeckendes Netzwerk daraus zu machen.
Also im Prinzip ist das so ein Machine Learning System. Das heißt,
sie haben halt quasi die Mikrofone auf, den Sound, den sie mit den Mikrofonen aufnehmen,
auf diese Schaheds und wahrscheinlich auch noch andere Drohensysteme trainiert
und das ist eine relativ einfache Sache, die man heute schon mit einfacher,
AI-Hardware quasi realisieren kann und dann eben so ein verteiltes Sensornetzwerk draus gebaut.
Das habe ich auch gesehen, dass das nochmal News wurde, aber ich habe wie gesagt
schon vor zwei Jahren davon gelesen, dass so etwas entwickelt wurde und wahrscheinlich
haben sie in der Zwischenzeit daraus eben einfach ein komplettes Sensornetzwerk gemacht.
Gut, lass uns den Militärteil damit erstmal beenden. Wir haben hier auch schon
drei Stunden auf der Uhr.
So, zum Abschluss müssen wir vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen die Frage klären, also erstens,
was ist so von den aktuellen Verhandlungen, von dem aktuellen Verhandlungsstand
zu halten und gibt es hier überhaupt irgendwie einen Plan?
Weil man hat jetzt nicht so den Eindruck, dass das alles irgendwie nach Plan läuft.
Trump hat irgendwie seine Wahl, also im Wahlkampf ja irgendwie protzend bekannt
gegeben, er würde jetzt hier irgendwie den ganzen Konflikt in 24 Stunden lösen.
Nicht, dass es ihm irgendeiner geglaubt hätte, aber davon sind wir natürlich weit entfernt.
Und er hat jetzt irgendwie einen
Modus an den Tag gelegt, wo es halt verschiedenste Fragestellungen gibt.
Ist er jetzt wirklich ein russischer Spion oder dreht er einfach nur frei und
ist irgendwie unter Druck von Kompromat oder ist sein einziger Plan einfach,
das wird schon irgendwie sich von alleine lösen, Wenn ich irgendwie alle unter
Druck setze und alle müssen nach meiner Nase tanzen,
dann wird sich das schon irgendwie ergeben.
Weil ich bin ja Trump und wir sind ja die USA und das scheint ja irgendwie so
alles nicht aufzugehen.
Derzeit sind wir an diesem Punkt, wie schon erwähnt, Militärhilfen wurden eingestellt,
Informationsfluss wurde eingestellt.
Jetzt nach einer Woche wurde das Ganze wieder zurückgenommen.
Das könnte durchaus sein, dass es auf internationalen Druck hin geschehen ist,
weil er einfach gemerkt hat, dass er damit den Bogen weit überspannt hat.
Sein Verhältnis zu den Russen ist unklar. Will er von denen nur irgendwie auch
irgendwelche Deals haben und hat er sich bloß nicht getraut,
Putin gegenüber scharf aufzutreten, weil er der Meinung ist,
die Ukraine ist zu schwach und hat zu wenig Verbündete und die kann man schon
irgendwie dazu bringen, einfach zu sagen, so ja, okay, gut, dann geben wir halt auf.
Darauf könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass er das gedacht hat.
Ich könnte mir aber auch vorstellen, dass er überhaupt keine Ahnung hat von diesem ganzen Spiel.
Und ich meine, er hat ja auch nur Anfänger am Start. Also diese ganze Delegation,
alle Leute, die hier in diesen sogenannten Verhandlungen beteiligt sind, sind einfach...
Alle Leute, die überhaupt gar keine Ahnung haben von Diplomatie.
Also es sind keine erfahrenen Menschen dabei, es sind nur irgendwelche Cronies
von ihm, irgendwelche rechtsradikalen Spinner und sonstige Millionäre,
die noch einen Job brauchten.
Und das ist sozusagen der Stand der Dinge.
Jetzt musste er halt wieder einen Schritt zurückgehen, hat nach diesem Eklat
im Oval Office Selensky jetzt ein
Kommuniqué abgerungen, was sie jetzt in Saudi-Arabien ausgehandelt haben.
Nachdem halt die Ukraine offiziell gesagt hat, ja okay, dann machen wir halt
das mit dem Waffenstillstand.
Nur diese Bedingungen, die daran geknüpft sind, auf einen 30-tägigen Waffenstillstand,
was ja immer so die Formulierung war, die Trump hören wollte.
Daran sind halt geknüpfte Bedingungen wie, die Russen müssen alle Kriegsgefangenen
der Ukraine zurückgeben, die Russen müssen irgendwie alle entführten Kinder,
die nach Russland entführt worden sind, wieder zurückgeben.
Das werden die Russen nicht tun.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, was noch alles mit drin stand,
aber die Liste ist noch ein bisschen länger.
Auf jeden Fall sind das alles Bedingungen, die so in der Summe von Russland
nicht erfüllt werden können und wenn man den ersten Reaktionen Glauben schenken
darf, gibt es da auch überhaupt gar keine Bereitschaft bei den Russen in irgendeiner
Form auf diesen Deal einzugehen.
Und dann ist halt Trump wieder quasi in Zugzwang.
Kann ich alles so unterschreiben.
Und was vielleicht noch dazu kommt, also wenn man jetzt nicht nur seine außenpolitischen
Entscheidungen, sondern auch seine innenpolitischen und das mit den Zöllen und
so weiter zusammennimmt,
Und so entsteht nicht der Eindruck, dass da irgendwie eine Art von Plan oder
von komplexen Plan dahinter stecken könnte.
Weil Trumps Weltbild ist einfach und wie du schon richtig sagtest.
Er ist der Meinung, wir sind die USA, ich bin Trump und ich werde mehr oder
weniger alle dazu zwingen,
das zu tun, was ich will und dann anschließend den Friedensnobelpreis dafür einheimen.
Ja, er redet davon und seine Anhänger auch, dass Trump irgendwie ein öfter Kandidat
für den Friedensnobelpreis ist.
Das ist das Ding. Aber so in der Summe,
wenn man einfach die Summe seiner
Entscheidungen und seiner Kehrtwendungen betrachtet und den Schaden,
den er für die USA jetzt schon objektiv angerichtet hat.
Das kann man ja beziffern mit 40 Prozent weniger kanadische Touristen in den USA und, und, und.
Man kann jetzt halt lang weitergehen.
Also was sich einfach zeigt, ist, dass erstens.
Er nicht auf Basis von Fakten handelt, sondern sich Fakten ausdenkt am laufenden Band.
Oder beispielsweise, dass die USA dann 300 Milliarden gegeben haben und die Europäer nichts.
Solche Dinge. Oder dann von Vance kam dann das Ding ja schon so,
die Europäer wissen sowieso nicht, wie man Krieg führt und das sind alles irgendwie
Luschen-Truppen und damit quasi auf die Gräber von vor allem englischen Soldaten gepisst hat.
So die, also es sind 1000 Europäer gestorben,
wie gesagt und 150 Milliarden und
Europa hat mehr gegeben und das sind alles Fakten die aber Trump so offenbar
nicht heilt oder einfach anderen Glaubens ist so und ja,
wenn man irgendwie die Fakten nicht klar hat,
dann ist es auch eher unwahrscheinlich, dass man dahin kommt, wo man will.
Sondern das ist dann, ich meine, am Ende, ja, kann alles Mögliche passieren, aber es hilft nicht.
Es hilft nicht, irgendwie andere davon zu überzeugen, weil es einfach nicht
überzeugend klingt, weil es keinen Sinn macht.
Und es gibt mittlerweile auch.
Eine Reihe von Leuten, die der Meinung sind, das ist einfach jetzt ein gesundheitliches Problem.
Dass einfach Trumps Gehirn nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Dass er einfach der Komplexität der Situation einfach nicht gewachsen ist.
So und deswegen halt von Tag zu Tag, von Stimmung zu Stimmung auf irgendwas
reagiert, was zu ihm durchdringt.
Und ich glaube, es ist überall ein Stück Wahrheit dran.
Ich glaube, dass Trump einfach so, was seine intellektuellen Fähigkeiten,
Fähigkeit zu denken oder sich zu artikulieren oder einer klaren Strategie zu folgen ist,
deutlich vermindert gegenüber, ich würde sagen, der Normalbevölkerung.
Und das ist halt der eine Punkt.
Und der andere Punkt ist, dass offenbar das, was er tut, bei irgendeiner ganzen
Mengen Leuten in den USA auf Resonanz stößt.
All denen, die auch so ein einfaches Weltbild haben wie Trump.
Und das ist halt das Problem, das ist halt das, was gefährlich ist,
ist, dass Trump einfach, wie wir das letzte Mal gesagt haben,
ein Elefant im Porzellan laden und alle versuchen,
dem jetzt irgendwie was Gutes abzuringen.
Oder versuchen irgendwie eine Theorie aufzustellen, warum es gut ist,
dass er das ganze Porzellan dort zerschlägt.
Und mag sein, manches Porzellan ist vielleicht auch wert,
zerschlagen zu werden, aber unterm Strich können wir nicht von einem rationalen
Akteur ausgehen, der Entscheidungen trifft,
die nachvollziehbar sind.
Das ist so meine Sicht der Dinge,
wo man sich zwar erklären kann aus Trumps Vergangenheit plus dann Agenda 2025
plus diese gesamte rechtsintellektuelle in Anführungszeichen Szene,
die da noch mit reinspielt, das alles vermischt sich zu einem Klumpatsch, wo durchaus sagen wir,
geopolitische Strategien,
hervorscheinen an bestimmten Stellen oder wo man Theorien bilden kann,
aber am Ende des Tages ist es einfach nur Unfähigkeit, aus meiner Sicht.
Unfähigkeit zusammen mit einer narzisstischen Persönlichkeit,
wo Trump in erster Linie sich sieht und dann kommt erstmal lange nichts.
Und in der zweiten Reihe halt so die ganze Milliardärsgarde,
die hier die Gelegenheit sieht, einen relativ schwachen Trump irgendwie vorzuschicken
und für ihre eigenen Ziele und Pläne zu missbrauchen.
Irgendjemand hat gesagt, diese Milliardäre, die sehen halt irgendwie Trump als
CEO und sie sind aber irgendwie das Board und können ihn aber dann auch jederzeit
absetzen, wenn es dann irgendwie soweit ist.
Und im Prinzip nur der Gehilfe, um halt ihre feuchten libertären Träume einer neuen Welt umzusetzen.
Ich finde das sowieso so absurd, dass die Leute, die ihn gewählt haben,
die haben immer geredet von der großen Bedrohung eines Deep States,
der irgendwie so im Untergrund tut, wo irgendwie den Leuten Chips implementiert
werden sollen und die irgendwie daran arbeiten, eine New World Order umzusetzen.
Deswegen müssen wir Trump wählen. Was haben sie jetzt bekommen?
Elon Musk, der irgendwie Leuten Chips in den Kopf setzt mit seinem Neuralink-Projekt,
die irgendwie definitiv gerade dabei sind,
einen New World Order irgendwie zu installieren.
Und im Prinzip kriegen sie genau das, was sie irgendwie immer befürchtet haben,
was sie bekommen, wenn sie irgendwie Kamala Harris wählen.
Das ist völlig absurd.
Ja. Also, ja, unklar, wie das weitergehen wird im Moment.
Es gab ja erst diese Trump-Euphorie vom Aktienmarkt unter anderem,
wo es nach seiner Wahl riesige Gewinne gab.
Und die ist mittlerweile ganz klar verflogen, weil so seine Milliardärs-Buddies
haben zwar gegenüber dem,
wo er angetreten ist, noch nicht so viel verloren,
aber gegenüber vor zwei Monaten halt so.
Und einige wie Elon Musk haben jetzt in den letzten Monaten halt 50 Prozent ihres, ja,
des Aktienwertes, ihres theoretischen Vermögens verloren und das werden die
auch nur bis zu einem bestimmten Grad mitmachen.
Ja, aber sie tauschen das derzeit gegen Einfluss. Also da geht es also wirklich
mehr um eine politische Agenda.
Geld haben die genug. Also wenn der Aktienmarkt insgesamt zusammenbricht,
dann sind sie ja relativ zu allen anderen auch immer noch genauso gut dran.
Ja, also das ist halt einfach so eine internationale Geldelite, die halt, ja,
die Globalisten, also you get what you voted against und die sich halt einfach
auf so einem internationalen Parkett sehen,
das mit Nationalstaaten irgendwie nichts mehr zu tun haben will,
antidemokratisch und so weiter.
Ich glaube nach wie vor, von denen geht auch die Hauptgefahr aus.
Das sind Leute, die wirklich strategisch denken, die eine komplett andere Welt
im Kopf haben, die irgendwie an den Bedürfnissen der meisten Menschen vollständig dran vorbeigeht.
Tram geht es nur um sich selbst sozusagen, aber diesen anderen geht es eben wirklich um ein System.
Und von daher kann man nur hoffen, dass irgendwas passiert, dass dieser Spuk schnell vorbeigeht.
Zeichnet sich derzeit noch nicht ab, aber es kann einem durchaus auch sein,
dass das alles schnell auf so wackelige Beine gerät, dass es eben auch wie so
ein Kartenhaus alles wieder in sich zusammenfällt.
Ob das passieren wird, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, denkbar,
aber denkbar ist vieles.
Also für mich ist das Ganze geprägt von dem geopolitischen und historischen Analphabetismus.
So, wo einfach, ich meine klar, für
die USA, die waren sowieso immer sehr selbstfokussiert in ihrem Denken.
Und also was jetzt die Wähler betrifft, zum Beispiel die Hälfte Amerikaner hat
nie das Land verlassen. Das ist undenkbar im Vergleich mit Europa.
Und das erklärt halt, glaube ich, auch einfach eine ganze Menge,
dass offenbar diese Leute nicht wirklich verstehen,
wie der Rest der Welt so tickt und deswegen halt Dinge von sich geben,
wo sie überhaupt nicht wissen, wie die tatsächlich aufgenommen werden auf der anderen Seite.
Und denken, naja, lassen wir jetzt einen Spruch los, weil Worte sind billig,
aber sie sind sich nicht dessen bewusst, dass in anderen Teilen der Welt der
Großteil der Leute Worte für wichtig hält und ernst nimmt.
Und ihnen ist nicht klar, wie ernst viele Dinge genommen werden, die sie von sich geben.
Man erinnert mich so ein bisschen daran, dass ich irgendwann mal Geschäftsführer
geworden bin, war ich dann plötzlich in einer völlig anderen Rolle und war mir
dessen gar nicht bewusst,
dass wenn ich plötzlich einen Vorschlag gemacht habe gegenüber meinen Mitarbeitern,
dass dieser Vorschlag eigentlich als Anweisung interpretiert wurde,
obwohl ich es gar nicht so gemeint habe.
Es war einfach nur eine Idee in den Raum. Wie wäre es denn, wenn wir das so und so?
Und dann machen die Leute das einfach, obwohl das jetzt gar nicht so gemeint war.
Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen das, was dort passiert,
dass sie halt Sachen von sich geben, die sie gar nicht so meinen,
weil das einfach überhaupt nicht durchdacht ist.
Aber andere Leute versuchen sich dann einen Reim raufzumachen oder reagieren dann drauf.
Und zwar stark.
Und ich glaube, sie haben auch keine Ahnung oder begreifen nicht,
wie sehr sie die Kanadier zum Beispiel oder die Europäer jetzt...
Verunsichert haben und verstoßen haben.
Ja, verstoßen haben und was jetzt diese Aktion, auch dieses ganze Hin und Her,
wo man das Gefühl hat, das ist nicht ernsthaft, was sie tun.
An einem Tag steuern und dann.
Sagen Zölle, dann wieder Zölle zurück,
dann Einstellung von Lieferung und Einstellung von Lieferung zurück.
Das ist, das macht nicht den Eindruck von Ernsthaftigkeit, was sie dort tun.
Und sie sind sich dessen, glaube ich, nicht wirklich bewusst,
was sie in bestimmten Bereichen anrichten.
An anderen möglicherweise schon, aber ich glaube, ja.
Insgesamt, weltpolitisch auf keinen Fall. Jaja, also für manche ist Weltuntergang,
für andere ist es der langsamste Verkehrsunfall aller Zeiten.
Mal schauen, die Wall Street meinte ja auch zu diesem ganzen Zollwahnsinn,
irgendwie ja, das ist die dümmste Idee, die sie je gesehen hätten in der Wirtschaft.
Der dümmste Handelskrieg der Geschichte.
Der dümmste Handelskrieg mit dem Zusatz und wir sind da noch sehr zurückhaltend
in unserer Formulierung.
Pavel, lass uns hier an der Stelle Schluss machen, Sendung ist schon wieder
viel zu lang, ich habe so das Gefühl, wir werden nicht so viel Zeit vergehen
lassen bis zur nächsten Sendung, dafür turmt sich das Ganze gerade zu schnell auf und,
wir müssen das nächste Mal auch wieder ein bisschen mehr die Ukraine mehr in
den Fokus nehmen, auch wenn ich mir nicht ganz so sicher bin,
ob uns das dann gelingen wird, aber wäre auf jeden Fall mal relevant. Ich,
vielleicht auch noch mal einen
anderen Bericht aus der Ukraine noch mit einwerfen. Das sehen wir dann.
Ich würde sagen, wir sagen jetzt erstmal Tschüss und bedanken uns fürs Zuhören.
Hoffen, das war wieder was für euch dabei bei unseren Gedanken und dann hören
wir uns bald wieder. Bis bald.
Ciao. Macht's gut. Haltet die Ohren steif.